[Music]
you
welcome everyone to the football
tournament presented by the sports
gaming podcast and my book e dot AG and
all things comedy i'm shawn snagging the
money Green was my partner picks Ryan
real money Cramer what's happening
Kramer
holy Toledo Shawn we are here we are
alive we are across the globe and you're
bringing you football in July we are
live we're streaming on the all things
comedy YouTube channel so shout out to
them and joining us as always third man
to the booth colby dan AKA the dan to
base what's happened to colby pick in
the house how you guys doing doing good
and of course and maybe this is your
first time ever seen live simulated
video games we of course are the sports
game line podcast we have a podcast
where we normally talk about sports and
gambling sports unfortunately went away
so we've dove headfirst into the sim
world and basically what we're doing is
we're running back to 2019 NFL playoffs
same matchups but they have the 2020 NFL
roster so Cam Newton who's gonna be
playing later he's gonna be on the New
England Patriots Buffalo Bills they have
a couple Stefon Diggs they just got him
in the offseason so you'll see Stefon
Diggs and the best part you can gamble
on these games over at my bookie dot AG
using the promo code TFT and you just go
down the side there and click these
sports simulation bets and and shown if
you're new to Sims ya wondering why
we're seeing these very boring screens
of settings it's because politte people
will believe this is rigged people will
believe we are in on the fix so it's no
different than actual real sports it's
no different than real sports when
you're losing someone is going against
you that isn't just the team you bet on
Shawn yes I interrupted you I apologize
noise continue and you know the people
in the other things comedy they're just
like what is this what's going on of
course you can sign up for the the
challenge where we're giving away
$10,000 in my bookie dot AG credits all
you gotta do is go to sports gaming
podcast.com slash ATC sports gambling
PAC
calm slash ATC we're giving away $10,000
in my bookie credits nice sign up there
using the promo code TFT and it's pretty
simple you do like a little confidence
pool who you think's gonna gonna win the
most games every every win that team
gets is you get that many points
so essentially you assign 1 through 12
12 would be the team you think is going
to win the Superbowl and one would be
the team that you don't think is gonna
do like maybe the Philadelphia
Eagles
maybe you despise them maybe you despise
the Tennessee Titans and people named
Ryan I wouldn't be one of those people
but maybe that's you check it in on the
the all things comedy YouTube chat
sports rule sports do rule a great price
in Aaron Aaron Dawson and hope you like
all people named Bryce and they are
certainly a fit well well-structured
gentleman probably an athlete
Jacob Hatfield saying so how is this a
challenge exactly so the computer is
gonna be playing the game we're not
gonna be playing it at all the
challenges picking the team's you expect
to do the best in the playoffs you rank
them 1 to 12 again just go to sports
gambling podcast comm such a TC will
give you a little bit of time to get
your entries in and while we're doing
that we do have some player props over
at my bookie JG from a Coty ft to break
down Kramer what are some of the player
props that we got so far
oh you putting me on the spot good thing
I got him right in front of me because I
was studying for my own personal
edification Josh Allen I really like the
Josh Allen props we we are big fans of
josh josh allen one if you
one-and-a-half is that passing
touchdowns prop 42 is the rushing yards
prop as we like to call them in the
great game of madden and pay homage to
the great michael vick Josh Vick yes he
was on full display multiple times
during Madden mayhem and earlier 32
teams single elimination tournament we
put on and it's hard to not imagine he's
the same the UH the over is juste - 140
so I'm gonna I'm gonna pivot and I'm
gonna say Josh Allen throws for over one
and a half touchdowns plus 120 that's
gonna be one of my that's
that's that's going in the free Kraemer
gang package for the game free of charge
of course well and if you never watch
these Madden Sims a couple things that
are gonna jump out at you first off a
team with a mobile quarterback that
always seems to help it's helpful it's
very helpful they'll they'll scramble on
third downs pick up their downs and then
they have horrible clock management so
if you see your team driving right
before the half expect them they're
basically like the Andy Reid's of clock
management these Madden tips they don't
know what they're doing they're gonna
waste timeouts
you're gonna be so frustrated screaming
at the game as if it's a real game and
this is and yes we need sports back but
until then this is as close as you're
gonna get the football trust me if you
throw 20 bucks on this game 25 bucks
whatever it is well you feel you feel
the rush and I'm not even a big video
game guy but from calling these Sims
doing the play my plays that that should
be it man that's going on your epitaph
I'm not a big video game I'm a big
gambling and we can all agree we want
this we want the classic helmet though
right oh no no all whites right yeah
yeah oh it's looking pretty Texans are
an interesting team Kramer right now is
the let's check in on the live line and
that's the other thing too if you if you
hold off you want to bet later that's
fine my bookie dad Agee promo code TFT
they're gonna have live in game wagering
and we got a couple of minutes before
kickoff Sean so will quick talk about
the game but I'm gonna put you back on
the spot and give me a prop that you
like the Texans are six and a half point
favorites minus 300 on the money line
bills plus 180 44 and a half is the
total Sean we do this every game we
don't let Colby decide who our pick is
gonna be I think we discussed this a
little bit ahead of time and we were
willing to make a trade here you were
gonna take the the Saints on the NFC
side next Tuesday and in return I am
gonna take the Buffalo Bills pills at
six and a half no one circles the wagons
I love this play they they took a deep
run in Madden mayhem I look for them to
do the same here I like their future
Sean yes we have futures we have futures
on the AFC the NFC and to win the Super
Bowl over at my bookie Togiak n what's
up
Oh Joan TFT myplayer prop that I really
like deshaun Watson rushing yards under
52 and a half that is a lot of rushing
yards in this game and especially for
deshaun Watson
he'll scramble a little bit but 52 and a
half 53 that is a ton for deshaun Watson
I don't see that happening but yeah
we'll see again I'm nervous Lane six and
a half six points I would have liked to
take the Buffalo Bills Kolby who are you
on in this game from the start trouble
he called you Kolby though but I'm gonna
jump on this table if you guys let me to
once the once the once the Bills take a
big lead by half no no jumping on the
table we need it for later tonight
because there is a second game Patriots
Titans and of course Shawn there are
games tomorrow and I wanted to point
this out if you're new to this this this
is how serious we are we we forego this
warning that Madden itself tells us you
idiots are about to watch a game are you
sure yes we know what our our video game
ability to be involved in this super
scientific simulation of a Madden game
and if you're wondering is this gonna be
three hours like an NFL game no it's a
little bit over an hour and again the
live way dream will keep you interested
and then we have that late game Titans
against New England Patriots in New
England Cam Newton will be the starting
quarterback because of course he's on
the Patriots and can he do what Tom
Brady was unable to do and beat the
Titans at home in the playoffs and then
action picks up again Tuesday July 7th
Vikings at Saints Seahawks at Eagles
that's the Tuesday night action and Sean
we have two minutes until kickoff shout
out to the regulars who are impatient
the kickoff was a little later tonight
people are chirping well we but we got
you player props oh you're welcome
we got player props and again there was
a lot of letter ins a lot of outs a lot
of wires to connect getting everything
going for the live stream and and the
one last thing as a tradition please
let's see some emojis get this game
started let's get the the the football
tournament underway Sean my Giants can't
get it done no but before we start we
got to pick a winner right for the for
the whole thing all right I'll do it
gut reaction one future gun to your head
who's winning this whole thing don't say
the Eagles okay I'm not gonna say the
Eagles even though I really want to say
the Eagles we ran a 32 team NFL
tournament where the Kansas City Chiefs
took it all I would go with the New
Orleans Saints New Orleans Saints are my
team and if you're doing that confidence
pooled New Orleans Saints are definitely
a team you want to throw in there
because they're coming out of the
wild-card they get that extra game so
you have an extra game to score points
the size row then on the Saints woman oh
the Saints did way down then oh then
I'll switch it up the Kansas City Chiefs
give me the Kansas City Chiefs Patrick
Mahone okay nice and of course if you
heard Bill burr on our podcast talking
to NFL football we got this straight
great sound drop from bill where he was
being super sarcastic about how the
announcers just love Showtime my home
here's my one he lives up in the Pacific
Northwest he believes water can cure
concussion you're right hmm and goddamn
can he play football Jimmy Russell the
love muscle Wilson and Pete Carroll and
the truthers up there in Seattle um I'm
going for the ride again I know that if
their offense sucks in this game
excuse my French but let's get it
started Sean let's get this game do it
thank you everyone for checking us out
on the all things comedy YouTube channel
oh god this music is just I don't know
how kids can play these video games
anymore got Joe Perot there look at
those one pick overall get lost in those
eyes generation rising there's a joke
there something somewhere I call the
Colby we didn't talk about this let me
get the let me get pipe in the the
sounds from Buffalo
no this is Houston Graham I'm sorry from
Houston and here John or a Colby we
didn't discuss this ahead of time but
I'm thinking since we are on the same
side let's let's go full I like that I
like that call bills are turning out to
the 26 that's where they'll take over go
at full Jim McMahon yeah early enough
and let's go Josh Vick baby let's show
the people what they want to see first
and 10 out of the I formation handed on
Kevin single donor picks up one and down
he goes then I was checked up and I will
say Kolby you're gonna notice the
gameplay in this frickin game has
changed it's it's gotten better it's
kind of a little bit smartness and guys
split I Josh Allen under center second
and nine back to throw
Oh surveys the field check Siderius the
font digs baby Stefon Diggs sighting
complete a first down out to the 47 and
the Buffalo Bills on the move circling
the wagons early and often and I gotta
be honest it sounds like we're in Watt
and Washington right now with the crowd
noise people filing in late this is a
playoff game people we are talking about
playoffs winner-take-all
stand up Houston as the bills back but
you got to be impressed with Allen just
fire a dart Allen under center first and
ten nearly a safety knot and that's what
you get with Josh out you get some
amazing throws and some horrific throws
but yeah rough start there with that
pass a little bit of this a little bit
of that yeah no he's really hot and cold
and really where his value comes in is
with the scrambling ability and getting
it getting it going on the ground second
and ten Allen under center from the 47
let's do this Josh back to throw Kay
metric
it exists in the video game although
he's a baller he's a straight ball or
gangster from Wyoming if you remember
this game from the from when it actually
happened in 2019 playoffs bills got out
to an early lead they were they were
cruising and then and Texans made a
crazy comeback to win it
josh al with the only receiving
touchdown for the bills in that game
third and ten Allen out of the shotgun
to the bills waits and underneath to the
tight end it were Houston territory Oh
should have won that game dude there was
a terrible crack buck crack back block
that the couple back calls late in that
game that got him out of fuel low range
on what would have been a first down but
yeah we're gonna get it done today
it's okay revenge is on the mind Allen
under center first and ten at the 38
bills on the move hand it off to
Singletary
runs around not much room there yeah you
know you don't like the cha-cha-cha
stuff I feel like that's the runningback
equivalent to the cha-cha-cha dancing
around we like Singletary here but if
he's gonna be going left and right yeah
I might have to demote him off my top 10
fantasy running backs list Shawn because
the rookie from Utah who showed out in
the college football tournament yeah
he's on the team look out Moss Allen for
you out of the shack on second and nine
years in the hardcamp slides right
completes it again to the balls loose
pick it up
I've been there it's definitely gonna go
to the review Cramer has been red-hot
every sort of challenge they don't even
actually review it
deshaun Watson the Texans and take over
at their own 19 let's go baby
DeSean back to throat completes it
underneath will fuller getting him
involved early that's great they need it
that's not what we needed in games this
Texans team needs to get will fuller
going early and often
he's with no DeAndre Hopkins he's really
their deep threat fuller had a Notre
Dame and probably been one of their
better wide receivers they come to the
NFL I mean maybe him and Golden Tate
about the
whiteouts the past 20 years wants it out
of the shack your hands it off-- David
Johnson that's right he was involved in
it DeAndre Hopkins trade picks up a
couple third and inches and Sean if you
want to get involved in this game you
tuned in you're like dang I didn't get
my bet in that's alright we got a live
number up over at my bookie dot agh
still six and a half minus 350 on the
money line plus 194 the bills 42 is the
total promo code TFT Watson of the shack
on third and inches reset back to throne
[Applause]
you gotta catch them I felt good about
it all right there is there is some
weird thing going on with the game again
if you're new to the Madden Sims third
and inches third and one fourth and
inches fourth and one well thanks Green
they just can't help but but mess things
up and again they run a frustrating
amount of bubble screens and they'll see
those as they go along what we're
talking about the bad things there's a
lot of great things they're doing this
game too yes the best thing of course is
allow us to gamble yeah
picks up a couple on the return bills
will take over at their own 19 they had
a great first drive blew it all with
that fumble and now they look to take
things over here and get it going the
second try great if you're an under
better great first couple of drives here
still 10 37 left to go on the first
shout out to Nick 2480 who says he
missed me Sean you know yeah good people
I mean just in general they they a
couple I welcome to UAB went as far to
say that the show was not the same
without you Wow
I mean strong endorsement shots fire
takes another JJ Watt with the tackle
Singletary picks up 0 second and 10 I
mean this early take on this game is if
you're a Buffalo back or you're loving
the flow if you're a Houston backer
you got to see the offense do a little
something much like Russell Wilson up
there in Seattle very frustrating a lot
to Shaun Watson
no help from the coaching staff year
after year Josh Allen out of the shotgun
second and ten from his own twenty kids
off to Singletary get a little bit he's
got a 29 inches the dreaded third and
inches I think they're down for Buffalo
kick it just kick it
oh I can't it's just such a small amount
I can't see he's got the first down the
yellow lines not official what did that
get that index card out there that gets
get a measurement Allen counter center
13 inches are throwing it danger says
nearly picked off I'm taking the glasses
off Colby we're gonna come we're gonna
circle back late yeah I'm with you
it's not working it's not working it off
you man ah we got some we got some
people checking in on the all things
comedy YouTube channel couple of haters
saying this show is terrible with or
without you beautiful that's a lateral
movement take it not the first time you
know my father would tell me the same
thing shun perhaps this is Kobe's father
I didn't look at the user name the
database is dad Tim of the Internet
aren't necessarily best friends like
father like son right sure exactly again
great start for the under first and ten
at the 18 Texans taken over I mean this
is we're gonna see something bad he'll
be Oh Charlotte Singh complete scene
that's one this is a sim guys you can
hit him as hard as possible yes all
right we're not gonna throw flags they
don't throw many flags from roughing the
passer zero or targeting illegal hit to
the head second and one so just um dude
you lost that ball out there just
absolutely take your helmet and shove it
right in his Adam's apple
old-school football style no CTE here
yes Watson under Center second and one
see what I did there Colby I love it
buddy
fuller in motion all right we got some
ATC chat guys checking in Trevor Finley
hi guys what's up dude
shout out can someone tell bill burr I
said hello
will do there he is saying hi back
Matt mallanna with the fumble return
Trevor Finley already looking for some
NHL 20 next hey we're not above they're
not above some sim hockey I hadn't even
crossed my mind and it shot 94 how about
the greatest Chris Chelios yeah that was
peak for a couple games Madden was
pretty good that year to Milan under
center i-formation hands it off to the
full-back dude we gotta get seven come
on
no this is foreign matter until would
love that give him the ball to the
full-back he's one of those guys we'll
get penetration chill bill 420 is this
AI versus AI yes this is AI versus AI
the computer is playing itself you have
a chance to bet on it my bookie dad AG
promo code TFT live in game wagering is
available Allen with the hard count
let's 3rd and goal from the 5 let's go
to yellow because it wait
and is that is that does not dig he
needed add to fumbling early he did
redemption for Josh Allen and Stefon
Diggs and Kramer were you on the Allen
passing touch that one that's one baby
the Kramer gang stand up were halfway
home and and I know Diggs is a receiving
prop was like six and a half
that felt high but he's already had
about three I believe he's got three
already I mean III took the the cooks
under six catches so so far so good
Joe s checking in on the all things
comedy what the f is this this is what I
call content Joe you sound like one of
us sounds like he needs to head over to
my bookie AG get a new account use that
promo code TF t get that deposit bonus
and then he can participate because the
live line right now is updated to Texans
minus two and a half minus 145 on the
main line bills bills plus 146 and a
half is now the total tion I didn't even
still - 110 each way so if you want to
bet on the point total otter even again
you're probably a degenerate you'll
probably like us we've kind of buried
the lead out watching these games we
recommend you know if you like the drink
oh we like to John Cheers
salud we're drinking a bunch of juice in
the studio again like watching a regular
football game you enjoy a beer a
cocktail probably probably
it makes the game experience a little
better for my nose beer basically you
know Vegas has been closed we this has
been the longest
hiatus from Vegas in my life my
no line Jonathan Baker chillin filling
the gap Shana
saying it looks so real I know again I'm
not a video game guy but if your wife
walked past is your girlfriend they
probably thought you're watching a real
game Watson added a shotgun first and
ten
Oh complete I like that interior push on
if the bills can mate like the key to
beating Watson is just putting him in
the ground and holding him down so get
some hits on him early wear him down
we know Bill O'Brien is not a smart man
and we know Tremaine Edmonds in that
defense getting in there Watson under
Center second and ten and Oliver playing
despite didn't you get a DUI or
something we see that yeah they injuries
and suspensions don't apply in the
football tournament
hashtag TFT only pick up to Houston and
third Nate this is not where this Texans
team wants to be Hawaiian built checking
in on the ATC YouTube tbh don't know any
of these guys but I'm a plus for dealing
with this simulated game Thank You weed
they you know where to we're too out of
control and reckless to broadcast Monday
Night Football they put us down in the
same world
Watson oh my god looks like trash how do
receiver wide open horrible throw what
do you call those again like we're
burners I think and that was always
McNab's trouble within the ball into the
ground and and and stron shout out to
the regulars over in the twitch channels
the sports gambling podcast my bookie
Madden
[Applause]
let's block a punt this game Texans out
to punt we should encourage those d
Gentoo the ATC YouTube chat mix it up
introduce yourself say hello to the new
family Trevor Finley checking in saying
he my dad thinks NBA 2k is real
sometimes it's real to us bro it's much
like that the guy watching the wrestling
video it's still real the me and you
don't got to worry about Kyrie Irving
playing now our world is round
Allen under center first and 10 this is
huge if they can go up to scores
oh there and Texans are gonna be in
trouble Oh
hands it off the middle the Singletary
breaks the tackle eyes and watt forcing
the fumble it looks like what the heck
three fumbles already in this game
that's unusual when wound Chaya y saying
you should ask EA if they're gonna make
franchise mode better I know all the
Madden truthers are just so mad at EA we
are too bro
we are too we've watched a lot a lot of
BS in this game Allen under center 2nd
and 2 from the 28 the single sorry yeah
looks like walk out in there but the
cornerback made the tackle Singletary
couldn't pick up the first down what
concern is one then if you're showing up
late there is a late game Sean it's good
kicking off after this game at 7 p.m. on
the west coast 10 o'clock on the East
Coast Titans Patriots Patriots have Cam
Newton Allen under center third one from
the 29 if he just ran it like in a hole
I mean on third down Allen and deshaun
Watson looked horrific throwing the roll
he must have missed that whole Cramer
because of you know the
eyes apart thing that what's what do you
call it
Kramer's came at the campus measurement
between these between your pupils
that's how Kramer rates comport about
one of the metrics I use to determine if
you're gonna be an effective franchise
quarterback deep one rolls into the
endzone texted to take over on their own
twenty Dave 1971 to know what's the
turnover over/under I'm sure we've
already got three that's a lot no
because some of those were recovered
right with the two turnovers turn over
this game it was probably three and a
half with Watson and Josh Vick out there
Watson under center first and 10 from
their own 20 hands it off shout-out to
Nick the bookie Slayer over on Twitch
this game asked is okay okay he's
here every night every night it's a slow
start to the sim world we've seen some
turnover it's getting things a little
exciting hope hopefully scoring picks up
Jackson Hall Allen under rushing yards
looking ok for now
I went with the passing touchdowns I
feel like I've made the right decisions
ok and deshaun Watson hasn't ran the
ball once so my prop of him under
rushing yards they get on the chip sweet
3040 poppin theirs down near midfield
first down at the 40 no great play call
they were showing blitz they had
everyone loaded up front take the speed
to the outside and he stepped over and
said how's the view from from from under
Wow breaking is celebrity in the chat
Ryan Fitzpatrick okay Fitz magic saying
just got here already loving what I'm
seeing nice
we love you Fitz magic hey yeah I think
you started for both these teams he
started for every NFL team like that oh
my god dude him and that beard and that
gold chain
you guys still run there on first down
second and five the heard the
Jets cut him to get Sam darling a
mistake personally thought it was
that sim Brian Flores started
to over in the mad Mayim term that was
complete but of course Cam
Newton will be starting
in the wind okay but Johnson's gettin
going is the best we've seen him play so
far in the sim world yeah I'm certainly
not gonna be involved in any David
Johnson ownership in a fantasy football
he's gonna be I don't even know if
you're allowed to describe it like that
anymore but I I don't think I'm gonna be
putting David Johnson on my team just
because the concerns
he's look he's the Rudy story man is
from a small school Northern Iowa FCS
same schools Kurt Warner I'm just going
against Bill Brian's offseason moves
well that's logic deshaun Watson with a
play-action now he looks to run here's
that over of the yarns dammit it's tough
because I'm betting on the Texans to win
the game and cover six and a half but
I'm also going under Watson rushing
yards so it's tough I'm Rudy I wish you
would have only picked up like five
there but when he got 1011 then I love
it I think he's on paste what was that
number what you want to if it was very
high so I thought that was Allen 52 in
the hand no I I think Watson was 52 and
a half but maybe I'm wrong I had to look
at it Watson play-action first and 10
dick old dangers forehead that's I'm
talking about hit him he didn't have any
zip on that ball if I'm rooting for the
Texans I want to see him fire that
pigskin not Lauder you know now
shout out to Madden for 20 in the chat
shout-out to dick Gertz burger always
Blanco that's the dude right there
drinking this Jameis and then he bought
it Watson out of the shotgun hard count
fuller in motion second and 10 from the
26 Oh hands it off to Duke Johnson
junior first carry of the game that's a
first down for your Houston Texas the
set is it a junior or the second I know
I'm getting confused nowadays with the
way they title themselves whoever that
linebackers I was trying to get that
number I missed it just completely
whiffed who did I read there's a
division 2 football I'm back or playing
it like North Dakota State who had the 5
next to him he was the 5th
just overall the number of five get it
going to david johnson strings it out
it's not much there it's not Jamil
concentrator - it was you know late
night I'm trolling around red and I saw
some hilarious story and the guy just
had a Roman numeral five on his uniform
and I just like that's pretty that's a
pretty boss right yeah say like
come up with a new name georgia tech's
corner is tres willing he's the third
swelling they call him tre that's pretty
pretty pretty good bubble screen went to
will fuller and that's the bubble screen
if this is the first time you're
watching a madden sim they love crowbar
and in these bubble screens they never
work they look lose two yards they're
third and 11 Jackson hall a checking in
same cam will prove Brady is a system
court of a system and this time do you
guys want me to go off on this in a
positive way if you're a first quarter
better bills and the under hit cash that
and Bill score first stars also already
hit Watson out of the shotgun third and
11 completes it no he got that there's a
thing called board press Colby first and
goal of five didn't know the Sims had
that man people are saying that I had
the kovat on Tuesday Sean don't we and
again we would all all positive kovat
nineteen tests will become public
knowledge in our studio Hawaiian built
same fun game for you guys take a shot
every time they decide to throw on third
one I don't know we'll probably be on
the floor
oh man we go baby does Nick up much he
does it 15 so he cuts them listen to
that over again this is really this is
really annoying rooting against the
rushing yards props wall so rooting for
the Texans to cover the six and a half I
mean it I hate the way the linebackers
just hesitate for that second on the
quarterback run dakara saying Matt
Cassel already proved Brady was
assistant watchin complete for the
touchdown
to the tight end David fells here we go
Houston still hasn't thought about a
cook so I'm happy yeah
cooks under receiving props looking
great right now was that the the pick
Gundy special that was the picked undies
special and Seana I you know the Kramer
gang this this doesn't make us feel more
relaxed over betters once again I
thought about calling it out there feels
like it's too late now 14 points early
into the second quarter live number over
in my bookie AG and her buddy uh NB 36
Watson over two touchdowns lfg that's uh
I mean that feels pretty good I mean for
both cubies you got to thank you look
you're sitting pretty the live number is
Texans - 5 & a half - 2:45 on the money
line bills plus 150 47 and a half is the
total so we're almost back to where we
started Sean tie game starting second
quarter I mean Bills offense so if you
take away that fumble return they've
done nothing absolutely nothing
Trevor Finley checking in saying got
shafted last season drafting Duke
Johnson instead of David Johnson rookie
mistake I I also was kind of high on
Duke Johnson I thought he'd be involved
in the passing game or you know full
point PPR you want to get those pass
catching running backs Sean what do we
got screwed by the Duke as well Dre day
wants to know what are we drinking slip
it on some black barrel jameson on the
rocks the unofficial drink of the sports
gambling podcast bills were turning out
to the 24 and Shannon of course to Magic
Man Blanco friend of the program sending
in those bottles
hell of a good American we've I mean at
this point we've gone past the bottles
he sent him yes it's been a lot of
nights a lot of days a lot of nights
just been toiling in the sim line
bringing people content that they can
bet on
have fun have a couple of cocktails
pretend like you're watching a real game
Alan under center first and ten hands it
off Devin Singletary
I hope they run out of this too tight
and set the rest of the game because I
like it and shout shout the brazen Gator
fan over on twitch saying nose beers
cheers guys
hell yeah crackling open yeah shout-out
to the nose beers we got a Trevor new
gambler of course the money line is
you're just betting on the team to win
over under is over basically you're
betting whether they go over or under
that you know usually it's for the
points like over/under points in the
game
right now the total would be 14 so we
need to deploy some of the degen to head
over and beat beat two Sherpas Adrian
Chiles saying I want to see Tampa Bay
unfortunately they didn't make the 2019
playoffs you won't see them we're doing
we're doing a bunch of other sins so
they definitely make it in those Gary's
there was some weird glitch there where
just bounce some pool Beasley's head
come on dude Cole Beasley a product of
SMU and playing for June Jones legendary
offensive coach let great head coach but
check us check him out he came on the
podcast about a month ago boy oh boy
that was a bad play he was uh he we had
the first down bills three and out and
now Texans will take over get a little
bit of return here out to the jacob 23
punch him alright guys it's time for
another turnover it's time for another
turnover I'm looking at you at Oliver
right yeah Josh Norman perhaps Kramer
what's the what we have any movement on
the live number it's back to where we
started six and a half - 350 on the
money line plus 194 the bills
of course you can bet that you'd add AG
promo code TFT David Johnson nothing
they're second and ten total is forty
six and a half Sean I you know it it
almost feels like there might be some
value in the under I I don't feel both
teams have basically had one opportunity
score haven't really looked good the
rest of the time and you know I think
what we're gonna probably see is it's
gonna come down to is there a defensive
touchdown or not for it's pretty much
already one got down to the 4 yard line
David Johnson picks up a couple Kramer
really a special request here someone
asking give me your best EA sports it's
in the game maybe you should take this
Kramer
oh well because I say das Bundesliga a
sports it's in the game I think you got
it nailed it it's in the game six
completes it to the outside that's a
first down
I'd open for the Texans still not cooks
them as long as it still is I'm happy
yeah cooks it has he had a catch so far
I don't think he s that props looking
good maybe you got traded again if we
don't even know you gets traded every
six months Florida number one pick every
time I don't know how that works out
Watson Center I'm sure the Jets will be
the next victims and just say hey happy
third pick in the draft for cooks
looking losers
little nugget about to Shawn Watson he
became the only starting quarterback in
the last 15 years to have a 14 point
comeback in both the college playoffs
and the NFL player and McDermott's hat
looks way too big for him so yeah I
didn't finish creating his head what you
said the last how many years was that 14
years you said no just uh
now it can't be ever did anyone have
that - Howard did anyone take the over
and Titus Howard Russia oh this guy
tumblin yes some speed look at that big
man move oh man a shame he couldn't get
it in the end zone false start if it's
on him I understand it he's winded means
it catches her breath it was any broke a
couple tackles that Wow
and another fumble in this game we've
seen a ton so far he had the ball just
he was running with right out there I
thought potential fumble again but now
well Colby I think the loophole on the
stat that I gave out was college
playoffs and NFL playoffs so the
relatively round because I was gonna say
Frank right you know Don Beebe told that
story on the podcast of Frank Wright you
know he came back from I think 30 to 38
to 3 right 30 in college and pro yeah
loses to their second and call from the
11 oh my god that was a that wasn't a
mitt like that's going into the
highlight oh definitely
definitely that was a lineman just ran
the ball 50 years so close to scottson
spin move oh what's the one and down he
goes
now does that affect the rushing yards
you wonder Sean no sax should count
against the passing yards no I mean he
was clearly trying to run but I think
they still rule that as a sack and
people are wondering why balichek never
depicted in the game he never sides off
verse to cool the hoodie
[Applause]
I bet you'd sign off forgery Glanville's
pigskin up whoa that was our chance
right there and if you're if you haven't
heard an episode of the podcast perfect
time to hop on
just look up sports gambling podcasts
Apple podcasts wherever Spotify wherever
you listen to podcast we just had jerry
glanville on your younger listener don't
know who he is
oh my goodness he's like he's like
hunter s Thompson if hunters Thompson
race NASCAR the Falcons Nick Saban his
first pro game yeah
nearly blocks that looked like the
blocked field going animation we've seen
a couple times man this is this games
been exciting for a 10-7 gate we've seen
a ton of action yeah I mean honestly if
you listen to the Jerry Glanville
interview and you're not entertained I
just I just don't understand what makes
you laugh dude I had a friend from high
school hit me up who doesn't even watch
football and he's just like dude I don't
know who the hell that do it is but he's
hilarious
yeah our horse-racing expert he lives in
England who gave out the trifecta for
the Belmont Stakes hell yeah he goes
I've never heard of Jerry Glanville I
listen to the episode he goes that guy's
amazing I'd imagine that there's a
certain novelty element that if you're
out from outside this country it's
pretty amusing to listen to a guy like
that tell story Anna was bigger than
football he we had Paul Newman
references Kris Kristofferson MC Hammer
so stories with all of those guys check
it out
Evander Holyfield gave a pep talk to the
Falcons but did not go well bills were
turning out to the 27
all right Colby somehow we went from 7
up feeling good super relaxed now we're
now we're in a spot or it's either we we
make a play we answer or face going down
10 Sean let's uh I just man
we need to see Josh Vick activate the
live numbers oh yeah what elephant's has
been awful they're not on the same page
Alan out of the shotgun it's not gonna
change a what and this is interesting
because in these sims so far where we've
seen the Texans JJ Watt hasn't done much
but he's having himself a game yeah
the updated number Shawn we're back to
six and a half and I'm feeling good
about six and a half Houston seem to
figure out their offense just fumble and
let the often sublime and run for 50
yards
hey brazen Gator fan yeah Jerry
Glanville's pigskin football was a real
game it was fantastic Jeff Singletary
catches the ball out of the backfield
picks up a couple not much out makes it
third and a little bit more manageable
third and 11
someone says soon as I can talk about
everything except sports gambling wow I
don't even know how to respond to them
we've just been giving out the live line
for a video game and you're talking to a
guy that won $200,000 over here I'm
putting his lineup on the podcast prior
to winning deep ball by Josh Allen Oh
Steph goes oh and makes the grab
are you kidding me that's what I'm if
you're a Bills fan you love what you're
seeing this is exactly what I told you
Sean Diggs is the perfect Josh Allen
receiver he has a massive test catch
radius so Josh Allen's incredible
inconsistency and inaccuracy problems
won't be a problem with the fans and on
our top 10 fantasy football quarterbacks
I made Allen number one partly for that
reason and his rushing yards rushing
touchdowns completes it to the tight end
picks up five second and five from the
seven Allen hasn't ran much so far no he
has that it's kind of surprise for is
looking like it's dangerous I don't even
I can't even think of one run yet delux
picks checking in st. digs over
receiving yards yeah that's looking good
after that catch for sure Allen out of
the shotgun second and five from the
back to throw Knox's opens tucks it away
huh give me a little jus but now much
there you loses - it's good for the
earned 7 it's good for the over one and
a half passing touchdowns bra are you
gonna hit this yeah but to say you're
about to get this two touchdowns right
here are you saying he Colby masterful
jinx because now they're not something
Horrible's Beasley touchdown Ricky Alan
out of the shotgun third and seven back
throw it's plenty of time to the end
zone Coley the database ake a pic Tandy
coming in with the the Jean impression
did I just give out a plus 120 winner in
the first half
don't even have to $20 based off that
plus 120 bet that Kramer gave out before
the game kicked off you could be feeding
your family right now
betting on these bad and Sims is Latrell
Sprewell in the trap he was broke after
he didn't take that 27 window he was
struggling his family with that 10
million doesn't get what he used to know
what member those like he had those rims
and he had those shoes with the with the
rims on the shoot or like that a wannabe
ram on the shoe and it was spinning
remember those remember it was an one
contract I believe whatever happened to
an one I think they got they got bought
by somebody huh they disappeared I don't
know I had the mix tapes they just
became the big three maybe they went to
China with Stephon Marbury
I see the professor's a big-time YouTube
star now some nugget about Josh Allen
he's the first quarterback to rush for
95 yards plus in three consecutive games
so not even Michael Vick now know it's
surprising but it is tough to have three
games like that in a row if you're a
quarterback jeans with a little bit of a
run there on the return and as we head
over to my bookie AG and of course use
that promo code TFT Texans are - two and
a half - 145 on the money
Bill's +150 is now the total Shaun the
over gang is starting to get super
relaxed here points are coming in heavy
we're at a good spot in this game to see
he lowers the shoulder and then he gets
blown up David Johnson picks up three
but he pays for so my god
Trudeau via swipe needs to go home and
report to class he was read x2 I thought
he was gonna do some damage and he got
straight-up
planted folded like a lawn chair as they
said all right Sean bit big drive here
for Watson they got an answer hand it
off to David Johnson again not much
thing I like it finish the tackle yeah
Jerry Hughes getting in their former TCU
defensive end plate under Gary Patterson
finish the tackle third and six for this
Texans team and these these teams both
teams have had trouble converting on
third down so turnover this is huge
turnover load Watson out of the shack on
third and six hard go boys back to throw
now he's gone
now he would this is a real game the
bills player would be Edmonds will be
thrown out of the game if I'm nationally
real quick Colby we've not seen that
animation previous like couple weeks ago
right
like the linebacker just gonna flip my
CPU is a known that process learning
computer you know what Madden hears all
everyone and their comments about the
franchise mode they're trying
to make amends he's at my house with my
family my birthday cake I know they
really give you a heart attack with the
red banner flashing person ten bills
will take over they have three timeouts
they do they have a tumor to drive in
them I'm certainly looking to extend
this lead I'm scared here look Allen's
got zero rushing yards I thought that
would have been a decent bet to take the
over John what did I say before the game
don't go after that 42 minus 140 oh no
cuts it completes it to Knox underneath
picks up a handful second and four very
cha-cha-cha
when I when I tell when I tell the grand
Cramer gang to invest we generally make
money yes this is this is the originals
your investment partner this is the
original form of day training and that's
right Brian Ross Hakeem did have
Spalding member the Ewings I need to go
online and find me a pair of Ewings
remember those things
out of the shotgun second and six spin
move oh love it and and Houston needs a
convert on some of these they've had a
couple times where they've gotten their
hands on the ball couldn't pull down the
interception that could come back to
haunt him dudes from Wyoming he's been
bucked from a a wild Bronco before I'm
sure that's nothing
he's country strong you're looking at
the 2017 MVP of the famous Idaho Potato
Bowl Josh Allen third and six back to
throw complete Jesus I thought he caught
it it bounced off his helmet nearly
intercepted Singletary little shook who
was it that Singletary come on Kolby we
were not having a day at Singletary no
and the Bills have left points on the
board the Texans have left puts on the
bloppy game no one wants to win this
game sloppy game shout-out to Wilmore
man in the chat contributor over at
sports gaming podcast comm where we have
tons of picks Hale state articles Hale
state baby tons of free content over at
sports gaming podcast comm mm a call got
some amazing writers covering that as
well we even gave out free picks for
this game hot dog contest I saw hot dog
eating contest and you want a total you
want to lean we got you covered over at
sports gambling podcast.com is that
remember that used to have a champ that
was like a small Asian dude that was
like a hundred 20 pounds he was just
dominating dog eating contest
than they you know there's a lot of
drama and the competitive eating I know
God did a half time he has 30 but now
it's all about Joey Chestnut he's you
know Joey chestnuts is the is the new
stud right it's really a LeBron vs.
Jordan conversation with Kobayashi and
Joey Chestnut there was there was a
great thing like there was some weird
contract issue where he couldn't eat in
the contest anymore because they wanted
to design an exclusive deal yeah the
protesters showed up and and a chant of
let him eat was reverberating through
Coney Island it was one of the funny
seasons you know what you imagine that
dude dating what do you do for a living
I get a lot of hot dog second of
Mitch's Watson back to throw completes
it underneath that'll be a first down
for the Texans use the timeout there my
my favorite up professionally there was
eater X yeah who described himself as a
faith-based eater yeah I don't know I
don't know what your belief in God is
but if he's involved in a goddamn hot
dog eating contest I have no explanation
faith faith is important in everything
you do this 58 dogs for the big man
upstairs
Watson out of the shotgun person to the
39 has time see now they only have one
timeout which is dangerous in this game
who is that is that cooks that is cooks
which matches a game I'm gonna go to the
first half without a catch what it what
does the exert your clocks continue
innocent under six under six catches
yeah Nate mutant saying who are these
dudes where the sports gambling podcast
you can check us out sports gaming
podcast calm and yeah Colby and I are
stand-up comedians as well oh wow you
mate left out Kramer is a funny person
without a stand-up comedian do2 Shelley
Watson coming it's live we got this dude
let's gonna have three timeouts you're
in a dome here in Houston so look out
for a long field goal attempt
checks it down to Beasley it's gets out
of balance doesn't pick up much okay so
steal a couple points here could be huge
second and nine dude they say cooks has
three catches how did I miss those
what's going on am i doing too many nose
beers over here yeah I think so
three catches so right on pace the
oddsmakers know what they're doing i
poker Chuck 87 yes Cam Newton is a
patriot and you will see him in the late
game perfect ball
incomplete pass back on him 39 what Josh
Allen's just so he's so exciting because
it really could go horrible or amazing
it reminds me of an older but Bill's
quarterback named JP Lossman that was
just an adventure when he would go out
ride he was like Frank tarkington but
not good he was just run backwards and
crazy and just throw the ball up in the
air either way it's exciting 39 they
bring the pressure Cole Beasley with the
car we I wouldn't be surprised if
they try a 60-yard it's Hampton one I
think they just have to try the field
we're right I think you're in a dome or
whatever this Houston and real quick and
real environment JP JP lost but also the
answer to the trivia question of who was
the fourth quarterback drafted in the
2004 epic three three Hall of Famers in
there and JP loss and a Tulane one of
the green wait' and here we go
and the pills will try a 60 yarder from
the right hash it's up Oh short and it's
well short they should have put a
defender my Hail Mary baby
now Larry alright we're gonna take a
pause here for half time let people
catch their halftime bets let my bookies
settle those up and Houston will be
receiving the second half kickoff what
what does Alan have rushing I feel like
he's got like two yards
RJ moose knuckle checking in saying get
Doug Flutie out there no you know Kobe
loves the Doug Flutie right for my
all-time favorite player man
57% for both quarterbacks not an
efficient day Yahweh Allen doing much
better by the yardage if we had over T
rushing I mean it's just it's it's a
it's a hodgepodge and yeah I don't think
he has any Russian Wow
know if you would have told me that
coming into the prize I actually told
you God told people that exact thing I
said go for the passing proper coaching
but you would not have guessed zero
rushing yards for Josh Allen I was on
that track I was I was I was telling the
Kramer gang to avoid that tar pit you're
shaken with that answer you're gonna get
stuck in there and and let's see your
prop here Brandon cooks three catches
for 21 digs has to have gone over
already
one yards cash that if you have the
overrun Stefon Diggs my boy Cole Beasley
doing things anyone else we want to see
well I mean I saw the rushing yards for
my boy deshaun Watson 30 yards so he's a
little ahead of schedule but 52 and a
half oh they're gonna have to be thrown
the ball I don't know if they do they
have defensive player props and he
tackle Brown probably not I'll show
these just in case let them grade away
what are the rushing stats is the I'm
assuming the offensive lineman is the
leading rusher for Oh cuz it doesn't
count cuz he picked up the fumble you
know that's too bad they didn't throw
they should show I shouldn't how far did
he run biggest play of the game
prude Austin there's a guy's username
called prude Austin check it in on the
atcu jerk moulds i like that call back
bills need Eric moulds out there that's
going way back Hale state we are big
Mississippi we're a very Pro Mississippi
State podcast yes and that of course is
we're friends with Mike Leach
had him on the podcast a couple times
couple legendary appearances we got him
to rank the SEC mascots if they were
gonna do battle he and he was he checked
with us but we wanted to make sure
we were cool with visiting him down in
Mississippi before taking the job to
leave Pullman but yeah knew we loved
Pullman so much yeah yes we went up to
Pullman last year got to hang out with
coach leach gotta get the full Wazzu
experience up there and great coleslaw
sandwiches allegedly it was on it was an
awesome time for sure and hopefully
looking to get to a Mississippi State
game maybe the Egg Bowl we'll see
schedule holds for us if management over
in the my bookie Madden twitch could
tell us what time they'd like us to
restart give him some time to grade all
the halftime bets and Sean of course we
have we will have second half numbers we
might already have second half numbers
we do you want to go over that now just
real quick I mean the fact that the
Texans are only down four with only 52
passing yards they have to feel pretty
decent about that but no no wait a
second I need to look the rushing yards
must be included because I mean I
actually think the Texans all offense
has mommy you take away that 50-yarder
to digs the bills office has done
nothing do we we don't see the no III
don't think they're including that
fumble recovery but there's a hundred
yards I don't think they have a hundred
no I think they do cuz you're forgetting
that willful jet sweep that he got like
20 lakhs and has third you're right yeah
my bad yeah I mean Watson forty yards
rushing in the first half all right the
second half number again head over to my
bookie AG use that promo code TFT get
that deposit bonus and then you can
participate second half bills Texans
Texans are minus six so that's an
adjusted game spread of to minus 240 on
the Texans second half money line bills
plus 150 on the second half money line
so that's an adjusted money line on for
the game plus four and then twenty three
is your total team totals for the second
half Sean plus I'm sorry ten for the
bills Texans thirteen it sounds like
you're talking sports gambling talk here
well you know we are we are know what
we're talking about financial markets
we're not talking about gambling we're
talking about making short-term high
highly volatile investments that are fun
as hell
we're doing here we're selling positions
all right we're we're putting we're
coming yeah well we're buying favors
like you got to do that like wolf of
Wall Street
I watched Matthew McConaughey perform
that every morning when I wake up
Hawaiian built check it in on the
YouTube ATC great idea and these weird
times keep it up guys Mahalo to you
Hawaiian built prude Austin again that's
that's gonna be a tough username to beat
this is awesome so glad you guys are
doing this thank you guys Thank You
prude Austin and stay away from any
inappropriate contact Hawaiian bells -
prude you are check out our June Jones
oh yes legendary yeah and we all
calendar we also had nick role of itch
who is Hawaiian quarterback when June
Jones was coaching and now the coach
over at Washington State so we we go
deep there we're getting deep inside the
web of the the air raid offensive
pitching tree I guess you say well we're
also we're also hitting the fantasy
football hard Sean's favorite time of
year he loves ten top ten lists he loves
hot takes he gets to put them together
during fantasy football preview season
RJ moose knuckle saying you're bettin on
a videogame coronavirus has us broken
lol you're right we are betting on the
video game let's flip that and look at
it from a different angle alright and
let's say that maybe it's enlightening
us when the pizza man arrives you know
whether or marvel racing although I do
have I do have some we were doing that
with the kids it was a good time and
shout out to Magic Man Blanco who works
you know he works for would we say that
a public service septic treatment public
service so they're betting on ray
[Music]
I've been sitting in for the past week
thinking about that I can't wait for the
opportunity to announce one of those
things yes I doing paper paper airplanes
but no they do paper boats down the poo
river one of our listeners magic man big
friend of the program works at the
septic treatment place in Los Angeles
here they put boats down the poo river
and then they bet on who's gonna win so
we offered up if he sends it a video
maybe play-by-play hook us up Magic Man
look us up man yes sir
mayhem Mendes checking in on the YouTube
ATC finally a good reason to drink beer
thanks God all right thanks guys salud
shout out to drink and shout out to nose
beer it's the early fourth guys this is
you know it's been a crazy year for
America but hey we're here at the 4th
I'm proud to announce I will be having
meat tomorrow
oh wow it will be a meat filled July 4th
if you don't know Kramer dabbled in the
vegetarian the plant-based lifestyle he
coleslaw sandwiches he developed the
nickname soy boy for a while and it's
still it still hangs around and he
embarrassed this when we were at the
Washington State press box bye
they had delicious pulled pork
sandwiches and Ryan had the nerve to
take a Hawaiian roll pull it apart and
loaded it up with coleslaw and then go
back and eat it and someone poured it
out like that's white flour and like
mayo and shredded it's not healthy dude
that hold that whole weekend we went we
were in Moscow Idaho we went to that
burger joint now that guy said hey one
burger coming up calling him out
listen it's about the inflammation I'm
trying to consume less information I
just like what so what type of meter you
can have we're doing brats and sausages
on it Oh to the brats top the brats uh
who is a big big friend of the program
they are the best brats top in all of
North America if you're in the Kenosha
Wisconsin area make sure you check them
out they just sent a care package with
some hilarious brought related t-shirts
and a bunch of brats and cheese for us
in the studio shout out to you guys love
you guys are the best
brats up is legendary and yeah the one
shirt is like asking me about my wiener
some other you know brought related
humor
good guys over there
a lot of a lot of dick jokes because
they write themselves Shawn listen no
one's telling me it's time I think it's
time to create I just have a little
sauerkraut every night I mean listen I'm
you know III find you know we can move
past this I've already told you I it was
a moment of weakness I've already shared
in confidence that this was a mistake
and I had I had I had a choice to do it
again I probably wouldn't have chose to
maintain my no meat diet it's a good
thing when I went to a college campus
for a college football game it's a good
thing to get it I'm an idiot if you do
have a lot of inflammation issues I will
say no meat you know word on the street
up in Pullman is is that coach Leach
heard about this coleslaw sandwich it
was like I'm out of here how many that's
what he did he's dead these damn libs
all right so are we good Skeletor
management anyone let's get it going
let's get the second half kicked off
everyone got their second what was the
second half number all right real quick
let's recap second half texans minus 6
minus 240 on the money line bills plus
150 23 and a half is the total ten is
the team total for the bills texans are
13 oh 1050 anything you're advising the
greeny gang to get involved get in on
the over for the Texans ten points
they're going to put up more than 10
points no it's 10 for the bills and 10
for the bills 13 for the text oh okay um
I I still like I still like over Houston
13 points in the second half and I like
the over for the second half in general
I think my big play over 23 and a half
in the second half I'll say this though
with that you take away that 50-yard
pass by Allen the Bills offense has been
pretty much dogs you could say the same
thing about the 50 yard fumble recovery
run by the offensive linemen and a jet
sweep Doug and don't forget John we are
doing a game after this the kickoff is
gonna be around 7 o'clock on the west
coast 10 o'clock in the East Coast
Titans heading to New England to take on
the Patriots Ryan Tannehill against Cam
Newton Cam Newton and the Patriots
laying four and a half points - 220 on
the money line Titans plus one fifty
five forty four and a half is the total
there we'll be announcing our pick later
on this one we have not stay tuned Bert
is asking how many rushing yards Watson
has I believe it's 30 pretty great name
my favorite thing is how Colby reads
these names before he realizes them and
I'm just thinking it what is it The
Simpsons - the prank call guy yeah Mike
hunt zero Mike hunt in the Cherokee was
reading Richard Gertz burger before we
went all right I think we're ready I'm
seeing emojis all right let's do it
let's kick off the second half again we
are the sports gambling podcast
presented by my bookie dad AG promo code
TFT for the football tournament
broadcasting live here on all things
comedy all things sports Texans we'll
start with the ball second half at their
own 26 let's get it going
so what are you looking for here well
quick start right quick start they had
get fuller going he's that he's they're
kind of their best weapon on offense
cooks is easy completions to the Ted
NFL's sub cooks out he's that he's been
playing like
Trevor Finley saying I only came on
college games we've been simin NCAA 15
so if we can do that maybe basketball
and football we did both simulated whole
college basketball tournament completes
it to willful and that's what I want to
see completed the will fuller
that's a nice first down picks up 12 you
can argue we've done more for the sim
community than anyone doing college
basketball professional football college
football we had some tackle ball going
on on tact which I've been told you know
I'm gonna be doing some
fortnight Watson under center hands off
David Johnson had a bit of a hole there
could have picked up more only picks up
five second to five if you'd like to
maybe I'll stream some Master of Orion
- no no takers the dungeon master
Warcraft Warcraft to Starcraft you you
would play that wouldn't you
Red Alert RJ Moose knuckles saying you
guys ever meet Billy burr yes he's been
a guest on the podcast I I did a I did a
cancer benefit show with Bill awesome
dude as you'd expect incomplete pass I
mean I just have to comment you hang out
at the Comedy Store you can meet pretty
much meet any comedian legend you know
they may be like yeah and obviously it's
alive Phil's right up there greatest of
all time
definitely 35 from the 43 Texans coming
to show mots ins just been horribly
inaccurate yeah I was listening on his
podcast he flies helicopters - that's
yeah it's pretty badass lightning spells
really close to that first fourth and
inches give you damn it go for it
kick it they're gonna be you can't you
can't punt near midfield or in the
opponent's territory
you can come on and and Bill's got a
good show f is her family on Netflix
that's a great show I think they're on
the season 3 season 4 I've had some of
our friends on that Mike exits out to
punts god damn it that goes out of
bounds at the 11 that's a good pun not a
great start though shout out Trevor
Finley football games are longer in real
life that would that might be a bit too
much right you want three hours of this
yeah we get to get got to do we get
we get two games in having you know
yeah Allen out of the shotgun if you've
heard the college experience you know I
have no problem doing the seven-hour
game guys and shout out to the college
experience
Colby's podcast on the sports gambling
podcast network and he's breaking down
every single college football team 130
team 130 teams 130 episodes so make sure
you subscribe win titles game by game we
review last year look at this year new
editions coaching changes make sure you
returning starters everything yeah Allen
under center second of 12 you ruined it
hands off to single tear well there's a
you know Kobe the way it works is then
there's a call to action you stopped all
over the call to action now people don't
know what to do what they need to go
search for the college experience
wherever great podcasts are found yeah I
mean come on
isn't that implied no you check it in
seriously who the are these clowns
is this guy seriously commentating two
other guys playing a Madden game no no
the computer is playing it you idiot
yeah we went that would be we would be
losers comma dating two other guys
playing man this is the computer playing
itself and you can bet on it
so no we're not losers
[Applause]
John
[Music]
this not a great start for the second
half over but we'll see
oh nice Juke there out to the 45 we'll
call after the Texans to take over they
got to get points here because patty see
have kovat perhaps we got it we gotta
talk we got a what I test them rectally
I just feel like if there was one it
would be him I feel like first and ten
at their own 44 5 wants it out of the
shotgun come on dude get it going
quick pass underneath there you go who
is that that looks like cooks with the
permutations almost the first down
second in inches Kobe I jinx this guy
you're motion
Jesus Busch I caught the Beasley but I
mean come on prude Austin saying this is
legit I'm saying for the other game at 7
p.m. - Thank You / Dawson and then we
got the NFC games on Tuesday the 7th
same time I formation hands it off to
David Johnson picks up a couple and up
for the first down Texans into Buffalo
territory first and ten at the 41 let's
go Texans they need some points here
MMB says special he wants an SGP Pugh
River live broadcast well we can do it
remotely there's technology but I think
we might figure something out I don't
need to visit the pool River to put to
Watson completes it bullet pass to
fuller
but that's the kind of thing you want to
make sure you head over to twitch.tv
slash sports gambling podcast and hit
that follow button because I think
that's the kind of thing we put over in
twitch yeah I think Twitter's for that
kind of video games and poo races that's
what they built twitch for them 8 yard
pickup second into Watson under Center
from the 33
[Applause]
my action run it and now he's gonna run
it write it you got it
he's quiet slide see God he could fumble
but he doesn't first insurance I thought
he was at 40 no he was at 30 it's 30 and
a half time picked up seven there seven
I'm just way off over here work for the
record if you want if you listened to
anyone before the game on a prop one of
us has already cashed our tickets the
other two are desperately sweating out
an eventual loss
they call me pick 17 a prop Dundee David
Johnson the carry they're not a lot
picks up one second and nine bill burr
as a guest announcer would be fun on one
of these quotes I mean he could make
anything funny perhaps when the are you
saying we're not funny Toby Wow call me
I said he could make anything for as if
it's not funny today I'm saying like a
hug he goes laughing hysterically right
now I'd love to under center second and
nine completes it got a face mask
that'll be huge am its I'm licking goal
up at nine let's go so just run the ball
here are J moose knuckle saying you guys
think cam will do anything in New
England yes I think I win a Super Bowl
for the Patriots well I'm not gonna go
that far but I think he could
I mean if it's certainly the best case
scenario for Cam Newton I think he'll
piss off a fan base I think he'll do
that's guaranteed I just he's not
playing in a market like Boston I don't
know Boston's had Tom Brady for the past
20 years you know it's bound to be a
little difficult
Watson out of the shotgun first and goal
in complaint horrible throw Trevor
Finley saying who decides the teams that
are playing well of course we're running
back the 2019 NFL playoffs if you
remember this is wildcard weekend bills
Texans and of course Titans Patriots are
coming up after that so and Shaun if you
wanted to see all the information about
the schedule you can head over sports
gambling podcast.com slash ATC and see
all of that information
you gotta phone damn it and there into
the end zone how far we ambushed Dundee
hey well he's got to get two more
catches all right Cramer gang I've been
waiting patiently I haven't given out a
live play now but I think it's gonna be
time Jesus let's see what this number
surfaces as bi I think I've been wanting
to double down on this Bill's team
they're the better team in this game all
right Shawn Oh bills plus bills plus
four and a half is the updated number
over at my bookie AG of course use that
promo code TFT for the football
tournament plus 160 on the money line
for the bills Texans - 265 I'm still not
liking the numbers I'm not seeing value
bills plus 160 seems interesting bills
defense was garbage that drives complete
garbage every it's alright this happens
it's the ABS and the flows the pendulum
is swinging it's now time we have not
seen Josh Vic do anything miraculous ya
know yeah I don't think you think Colby
can tell you what question you know five
minutes to go Shawn they were down 15 -
the New York that was a crazy thing came
all the way came all the way back they
ended up winning by I think 15 points
yes they got like they scored like 30 in
the fourth
there was one of the crazier but but it
was all on the bun the on that back Josh
Allen in his legs in his eyes in his
eyes
well bills with the return out to the
you know what a 27 that's where a little
takeover you put the sunglasses on dude
when did you switch back Dave's a while
ago they were things have been going
good with the sunglasses I'm sticking
with the Sun I'm sticking with the Sun
they scored the second touchdown I
cashed a ticket with the sunglasses on
no you saying you're delusional if you
think scam Newton is going to take the
path to the Super Bowl again who said
that Kobe did i I've always given
as I coined the phrase a ton of crap
[Applause]
that's awesome for Texans - six and a
half that's awesome for the second half
over and I said Houston over 13 points
in the second half that just cashed well
once a at the extra point
let's go baby Jesus just brutal just
brutal let's build offense has been dog
all game but but coming back to Jim
Newton I mean he's a guy for me never
gotten the most out of his talent and
he's had the crazy shoulder surgeries if
he's completely healthy and if Bill
Belichick builds his offense around it
maybe he can do a little something
certainly I think you would have to say
he's he's better probably the Jared Sid
and we haven't seen much but but look
and maybe I'm wrong with the Super Bowl
thing cuz he's on a one-year deal but so
best-case scenario it's all incentives
here the Patriots why not bring him in a
guy would like everything to prove total
incentive contract yeah and he balls out
he's gonna get paid so I mean it's cut
it again we called for this months ago
it's annoying but this is a classic
Belichick move now will I think all of
the reasons why people wanted to say
he's not gonna work out our
other than the fact of is it is you know
if he's he's walking in the building
with his tail between his legs saying
Belichick just lead me to the promised
land I think they could have a very nice
season is is he coming in humbled and
hungry that's kind of big issue at times
where it's been a little too cocky Josh
McDaniels got Tebow to the playoffs and
won a game period Cam Newton is the
ceiling of Matt Cassel won like 10 or 11
games and they didn't make the playoffs
it wasn't his fault this is an
interesting angle a position for Colby
to be in he's both brewed like rooting
for Cam Newton even before they got
Newton I had a ticket for them to win
the AFC East well certainly you feel
better with the
now Helen back to throw my where that's
intercepted oh my god II that didn't go
to the house and that the Buffalo Bills
and Josh Vick are unraveling here before
eyes what up Mike pack it into place to
be my feelings are okay oh my god David
fells turn around you don't
yeah how did that come on second and ten
Jesus that could have been another one
let's go baby
this is ridiculous this game just ended
and make three plays the game's over or
forget it's time if you're if you're
late that is it if you're looking at
betting live if you go to my bookie dad
AG and click on the sports Sims tab
you'll see the twitch feed that they
have gone which is the which is like an
updated feed so you can kind of see
where it's at
Prue Dawson nail in it looks like a
Bills playoff game alright and much like
like when they weren't Houston for the
actual playoffs not big and just
figuring out a way to blow this nine and
a half is the spread Shawn 750 on the
money line let's go Kramer gang but do
we do it now or later
[Applause]
Watson back to throw
bullet pass the fuller complete first
down at the 23 Shawn when do I buy the
money line or the spread is it gonna go
up well I'll definitely go up if Texans
score here which they if they score very
well get at least get a field goal if
they score a field goal I think it's
already built baked into the line okay
maybe it could even be higher could come
down with a field goal
touchdown maybe it creeps up a pointer
to ten and a half now eight to one is
the money line Oh Mike there's value
here I got a bite I got a bite
Watson hands it off to Duke Johnson
junior gets the outside Juke move at
plus 800 their downtime grammar gang
let's do a let's do a unit on plus ten
and a half Wow and let's do a half unit
on plus 800 so plus 800 again if you're
new to gambling a new baby eight to one
if you bet 100 hours you'd win up eight
hundred dollars if the bills pull this
out we'll see there is certainly behind
the eight ball right now Watson with the
play-action
we're Heat
dangerous throw he had Fell's open again
David Johnson saved it for what could
have been a sack or a fumble man great
blitz pick up Pat Lynch Ava's saying
gotta get old Billy red Bush on this
yeah of course
well we have we have uh we have virtual
Bilborough in the studio what's ahead of
the shotgun empty set third and seven
plenty of time bullet who is that and
they're just picking them apart right
now that of course your buddy Breen and
cooks Colby's got five six damn it they
can't have one more all right I can push
it would help if the bills would just
maybe have a long drive for once in his
game I'm done hey guys I love
the people in the chat arguing politics
like you're gonna change anyone's
opinion I was swung I changed my mind
after I was in a simulated Madden game
chat room you know it hit me I was uh I
was doing a few knows beers listen to
these idiots call a game and all of a
sudden I got into it was someone in they
they totally changed my opinion second
and goal at the one sorry what were you
guys talking about perfect time to put
things there put it in this high
formation heavyset Watson under center
there we go deep and I hold a three baby
I'm almost okay with that because now it
forces them to pass instead of just
running a Horrell horrible like David
Johnson carry it one more time this is a
massive play because six and a half is
right back alive with only a field goal
Sean six and a half becomes the winning
of the back door becomes wide open with
a touchdown
Watson out of the shotgun color the gold
from the five come on get there shorty
short go extend the patience let's go 40
now 41 yards he's sitting right near
that total fourth the goal at the one
they're not gonna go for it they're
gonna kick the field goal and now
they're only up 13 and I know I'm gonna
get lay in six-and-a-half I'm gonna get
the backdoor
cover by the bills when the backdoor
doesn't feel good
no it doesn't you want to talk politics
let's go let's go with the better
governor and predator
let's go shorts integrin California
Jesse Ventura in Minnesota or that other
dude they was like one of the Native
American that was Jesse Ventura just
likes to ask a lot of questions I'm okay
with that
if you if you have questions you should
ask just be like living in Mexico only
the grid yeah I love it I love it dude
he's my ceiling I gotta be honest I got
one of his books at the house he's a
very entertaining I aspired to live off
the grid six months out of the year but
just like extend the lead to 13 points I
wanted to vote for Gary Coleman to
become governor it was Arnold Gary
Coleman and Mary Kerry Mary Kerry the
porn that was one of the greatest they
recalled great David she should come
back now you know what I mean she should
make a run because I mean there now
everything's open you know that's why I
believe like Kanye could win you know I
mean not that I'm let's focus cobia I
feel like you're getting off the mission
which is willingness Bills team on the
service line I just always try to talk
predator we've seen this before I was
talking about it earlier Josh Allen
facing insurmountable odds Shawn what
could possibly happen next the Bills
defense they they've not done anything
from a pick six perspective I'm waiting
for that to happen well and Watson has
had some Darius throws Allen takes over
heavy formation i formation heavy said
I'm afraid it's go time boys
[Applause]
Zach Moss to Russia's no yards the show
for it
turn overloading babyface says over in
the twitch chat and moss had a big you
know big college and with Utah in the
Sims 2 performance and also the last
time we did Madden mayhem quiet day for
him
Allen under center
hands it off again the Singletary
offense is complete it's a lose
yardage is for 13 yards
Kobe your negative energy again we we
had this conversation last night right
you're bringing us down put the glass
time it was a time always bet on black
doubled up on the glasses Allen out of
the shotgun third and 13
play action has time spin move change
complete perfect where is feeded no
nowhere even close
we challenged that may nat jones tower
saying are you guys literally sitting
there and doing commentary on a sim game
scrubbing the stripes off the side of my
toilet holds more entertainment value
than that doing responding then why are
you watching hey i can't bet on you
scrubbing the i got a size of your
toilet i mean if you want to set a line
on it in my book he has some action that
[Applause]
review that that no way no it was down
all right the ball was loose early on
oh no for the regular turn I wouldn't
know anything about scrub return this
yes that's what we need a baby let's go
what what nat jones sour saying
hoping for something more I suppose
don't worry I'm going well what do you
want this is simulated games thank you
for checking it out maybe if you stick
around you'll end up finding yourself
enjoying yeah
Kobe if you were just a little bit good
more good-looking this dude would be
happy
I'm not been asked like I'm Casey Watson
and that could have been that the play
the bills need to get back in this game
second and ten you can't believe that
fumble that just gave me like so much
hope and then just flush that throw uh
you know throw a $20 bet on it give it a
chance I think you'll I think you'll
find it's more enjoyable
I was also skeptical of watching a
simulator video game skeptical scrubbing
my toilet yeah that doesn't sound fun
unless we're betting on something down
the pit River David Johnson picks up a
couple third and seven big third down
here and so what Houston has 17 points
in the second half looking good for the
second half over just need one more
touchdown third and seven Watson out of
the empty sets shotgun back to thrown
complete to the cooks and he the first
down give it to us sure give it to him
there you go you hooks my bet
Colby's practice got washed trade him
trade him
NAT checking in saying hard to check on
Colby's stats the shade hide his
beautiful eyes Colby maybe lower the
shades give that giving out a look into
the camera maybe we can win him back and
he hangs around the ATC chat they're not
brown they're not blue they're hazel
you're not swiping right on any of us
you know that we know that it's cool you
can say 420 saying Colby looks like a
six-year-old with the hat backwards and
sunglasses have you seen my papa lost in
the sports world and I did she I was
like I'd be classier professional
Allen of the shotgun first and ten from
the sixteenth heat tucks and runs and
down he goes that anything that's the
biggest story right now as Alan just
hasn't been able to get going right in
the blue haven't seen Josh pick maybe we
need to change the name on the back of
the uniform because this there's no
Superman coming he sucks
he sucks well I mean his eyes
are dangerously you know Frank Wright
was a backup and came in and led them to
the promised land perhaps Alan's second
or 12 and 14 the race is Jake for huh he
is and Alan has just been not throwing
the ball well yeah I mean there's no
other word to say he's just been
horribly inaccurate somebody said I look
like Andy Milonakis mmm that's not a
compliment I wouldn't take it as a
compliment Andy Milonakis doesn't have
gray hair come on oh yeah oh I mean I
have gray hair too anyone hawkins looks
like a child first down at the 13
complete to Stefon Diggs house I shaved
man you know what I mean got rid of the
shadow I haven't got a haircut since
March so you know it's been tough times
you know can't trust these barbers
Allen out of the shotgun first and 1013
left to go in the game back to throw
surveys the field checks it down the
coal Beasley picks up a couple second
and six I like when they go to Diggs I
mean he's just he's a superior receiver
there's a mismatch out there Allen just
keep it easy for him keep running these
like 15-yard comebacker 'he's he knows
how to throw that I like this they're
gonna space him out there's gonna be
room up the middle of the rope but to
run they don't spot
incomplete pass JJ Watt is destroying
this offensive line he's having himself
a game getting a ton of pressure prude
Austin did you guys see the combine
video with Josh Allen running we did I
think we posted a video of a meme that
someone combined him running with the
forest from Forrest Gump it was good
pretty amazing video you can check
another Instagram
third and six Allen out of the shotgun
Jesus what just oh
can we get this right maybe double-team
no no yeah I am someone says I look so
white well I do have both lights coming
at me I think listen yeah you're also
you're not a dark-skinned guy I am Irish
he is very white to live as close to the
beach as he does so I get melanoma go
under the ATM dude like oh perfect / oh
yeah look at that good punt by the bills
pin in the Texans at their own six
that's where deshaun Watson will take
over all right Sean let's head over to
my bookie dot AG where you're gonna use
that promo code t ft bills now ten to
one plus ten and a half Jesus 10 to 151
is the total John do you believe in
America dunderhead 51 over under where
you going we're at 41 right now I kind
of say under I don't know I mean I have
second half over so I still need seven
points but a lot of time left for only
ten points in my opinion that's true but
you would need 11 right yeah but I'm
just saying you you're not losing with
10 oh I know that's 51 and a half 51
yeah I mean that that's probably a good
105 on the / yeah all right you talked
me into it wants it out of the shack of
an executor 9 X 6 right here from his
own six hands it off to Duke Johnson jr.
jubes breaking a fumble damn it what's
up with this dude running like Jim Brown
third and four picks up six Wow all
right Shawn yes I dare I say this may be
the game I think if you allow Houston to
drive down and score here the game's
over so this big stop
third and four empty set to show lots of
Jesus right themselves I love it babe I
mean block punt right here these two
quarterbacks just horrific ly inaccurate
we used to have Virginia Tech who was
big big cheer big big fun chant with the
block that kick on that kick Oh
[Applause]
Texans after punt from their own 12
[Music]
[Applause]
Jukes if you do more than that though
you've gotta beat both those guys there
was a lot of space there first and 10 at
the 35
shout out to Mike Martinez Josh Allen is
an imposter right while I agree I also
may have him not as high as Shawn in the
top 10
quarterbacks list but I do have him in
my top 10 I think his legs just in
fantasy make him a difference maker in
real life the Kay metric limiting factor
he's
a franchise quarterback Allen completes
it to Devin Singletary alright John
I think the Texans can ice the game with
a stop here the game seems to have got a
little smarter with using clock if we
just want to get that field goal before
half we don't lose weight I'm not I'm
not gonna dare offend a Bills fan by
saying we but the shotgun second and
three from the 41 completes it too cold
Easley only a flag that's gonna be
Holdings coming back mother and that was
a big swing instead of a first down
you're still celebrating like an idiot
former cowboy NAT checking in again on
the YouTube ATC a chat room great
looking game though haven't played
Madden since 98 still still out Tecmo
Super Bowl once in a while yeah Colby is
one regional titles and he's Tecmo Super
Bowl so I got some hardware hanging on
the wall at home Allen deep set shotgun
Oh completes it to next play that way
the comeback is starting Kramer gang
hold on let's see what the live number
is Knox we might have to have some fun
nope not gonna have fun not not seeing a
number are they asking about the number
or asking I don't know management we
need a number what Ellen out of the
shotgun first and 10 there we go oh here
we go baby and here come the bills no
one circles the wagons like the Buffalo
Bills first and 10 down to the 28
damn this is a game Shawn even though
it's 13 points you got to be a little oh
I'm sweating the six and a half are you
kidding me Allen empty center of the
shotgun checks it down and get a
complete two cold Beasley oh if you guys
wanted to I mean certainly some
opportunity there we are we got the live
it's back to six-and-a-half Shawn 51 is
the total so if you had to do it again
are you laying the six-and-a-half yeah I
think so
this Texans team will pull it out I mean
deshaun Watson is a winner big play
right here talent out of the shotgun
second and three from the 21 handed all
kind of play close and they can't get
anything going on the ground a
Singletary 12 carries only eleven yards
third and fives the cockamamie play call
through to Austin Saint Beasley looking
like Don Beebe out there there we go Don
Beebe guest on the sports gambling
podcast check him out guys pretty pretty
fun I interview coaching some d3
football now it's pretty awesome al
ahead of the shotgun big third and five
it completes it which way you running
John Brown that's alright that's alright
he gets the first down
not much more after the catch and that's
our game novelist by the way jury john
brown's new book and I did love it first
and 10 at the 15 going in but that's
like a lawyer that's like a John Grisham
thing you know something like that John
Brown on the case ally out of the
shotgun first and ten from the 15
Singletary Marshall examine this
big-time play let's go Josh run it in
run it in
oh he's in the end zone oh I was here a
throne lien it a little bit more maybe
that's alright that was a good throw
great defensive play yeah
great play by the cornerback now cat Dan
know who's the most famous guest on the
podcast I like to think myself guys
yeah probably Kolby I'm gonna say bill
Burke yeah definitely
alan under center second and ten at the
fifteen not President Obama Donald Trump
all the greats a warble ball if he
catches that that's a pig six probably
would have Billy batts he's pretty
famous Sean's not paying attention what
about Billy batts he's pretty famous
Billy batts but Lenny Dykstra hit the
sound drop John let's go the slide I
don't know Oh Billy batts let me get you
shot do the lenny dykstra single
dairy third and ten Tammis gets it
they're gonna go for this right I think
they're smart enough to go for it
sometimes these sims are stupid but
don't have you stupid to score game you
gotta go don't be stupid
it's still a to score game if you kick a
field goal don't you do it okay
Gary guy formation there we go this is
horror thin - what do they do they're
like pump block there's running against
pump block and they blow it up just why
would you age a walk with a leaping tap
he looked like what wasn't a musical and
someone prances on the same - the
running has been trashed all day why
trust it right here against pump watch
go play action that was trash Bill's
blowing it that's worth NJ like there's
a better chance of the backdoor worst
chance of the bills winning the game
certainly Watson out of the I formation
first and ten of the eight hand it off
up the gut nothing there and kick him
when he gets down I just give them a
kiss forty seven and a half now the
total Sean pretty big adjustment we're
still what do we have still at 41 you
peer pressured me into that overcame a
lot of it over at ten and a half still
Oh controller batteries are low right
Watson under Center play action has time
go deep both feet in complete down to
the 30 damn it
huge grab I need a more whiskey no more
whiskey
we need a refill for the second game
save for the second game good second
game come work Titans Titans patron
that's that numbers down to three and a
half shown a little mile from the four
and a half there we go Jerry's Hughes
David Johnson why is he part of the game
plan 20 carries 47 yards Jesus Bills
Bills now plus thousand Sean twenty to
one you can bet on the bills right now
to win this game so if I had five about
$100 over at my bookie that eg promo
code t ft and the bills somehow win this
game give me another half unit you went
to grad I mean it's not that crazy seem
some crazy comeback sauce screenplay no
and David Johnson has room to run
blockers God he's so slow unhook
the trailer he's got what huge one is
bad he looks like those guys running
with the parachute time of their back
screen work after those college football
Sims I we've seen magic before we've
seen magic before bills have it they're
not dead now they're not pick-6 loading
third and three watson out of the
shotgun
from their own 37 back to throw deep
down the scent middle some plates in the
bills territory Brandon cooks
Highland himself the game after Cole he
said to take the under
oh man I'm I'm dead like Dundee Dundee
might have some problems here I need at
least a touchdown here right
Dundee needs a payday loan might be the
lay down under is getting a little get a
little hectic you bet get ya get some
free play you know Watson under center I
formation
play action pick six and now he looks to
run don't go down go down he's gonna hit
that he hit that Coby he needs 52 and a
half I'm pretty sure it was 42 I'm for
because I advise people not to look at
that and look at the over one and a half
passing touchdowns
the game's over now Shaun we should just
turn it off no there's a lot of profits
she's David Johnson with a huge hole up
the middle kick and shout out to the
chat who's got something they're
sweating right now
because I might just turn this game on I
mean the twenty over twenty three and a
half in the second half seemed so easy I
already hit the over Houston 13 but 23
and a half still need one more touchdown
and it can't be from the bills or that
screws Mike was it feasted - 6 and a
half was it 14 to 10 yes god damn it
bills really do know how to lose Watson
under center and David Johnson another
big hole you
they're gonna run you
know that they're gonna run they're
giving up we got it we got it under 42
we got it under 47 those are sweat why I
bet on the bills under 42 is about to
get a lucky break girls can't even win
calmly smoke for 28 EC really showing
this crap come on shouts you calmly
smoke 420 it's pretty fun when you
actually have a bet on it stick around
for the late game I think you'll enjoy
it smoke a little of your your weed
I'll see what he's doing there that's
what people in the chat dude shown they
they try to troll you because they're
having so much fun exactly
Watson under center play-action
second and two checks it down we lost
yours on the edge bills calling timeout
we're not dead yet Colby
how long will Phil go would this be
pretty long Brandon Lee in the YouTube
ATC what are you sitting on he's saying
can't let them score so low Gibson Crowe
dude well I know I know there's a couple
people shout out to my plums he's got
under 42 so there's probably some people
sitting and I think the total for the
game was 44 and a half so probably never
better sweating right now
Watson under center from the i-formation
play-action they're throwing up
oh no go down go down Oh does that still
count them for his rushing yards
I think damn it aah did the bills are
trash bills are trash
you should have slid Wow so I I got my
prop right you're welcome
I may have gotten I know I I think if he
runs they still get in the yardage we'll
see when the official scored I just got
a news break that Robbie Anderson has
multiple negative tweets and against the
New York Jets organization oh nice
perfect boys in Carolina right now right
yeah yeah well he's much ladies a lot
like you Colby it's tough
you had negative tweets against drew
because you hate what they do so much
it's at some point use you just got a
tweet about J McCarthy checking in party
on Jenny McCarthy J McCarthy party on
Wayne
Texans at the one-yard line second and
goal this could swing a lot of bets here
on the total hit play-action only goes
that's it the bills use it the last time
out well they may not score again here
because this is gonna get anybody to
might have just got him that's a huge
break for under 42 although they
probably will still kick the field goal
yeah cuz I don't think they can run
things happen okay
throw the ball throw it here have some
cojones
[Applause]
okay just gave a Johnson to the end zone
and that'll do it
second half over or go - that's touching
guy's horrible defense imagine having it
under bed you just got boned jeez just
boned if you two - Roman yeah oh my god
Watts another Center back to throw
there's no compares everywhere what's he
gonna do what's he doing and down again
33 1400 mad you see that grab for him
it's getting chippy it is well I mean
and this this tells us nothing about the
matchups next around it's all about if
the Titans advance they would face the
Ravens if the Patriots advance they will
face the Chiefs so basically the winner
of this game the Texans they're gonna
have to sit and wait for the late game
to see who they face in the divisional
round of the redu playoffs the runback
playoffs and once again shout to the
brats stop airing the games at the brats
up so if you're in the Kenosha Wisconsin
area head over the brats up grab a brach
grab a beer of course they got prime rib
on the weekends cheese curds hash tag
more than just brats
I mean what's more American than hanging
out at the brats out the day before the
fourth of July you know here and there
they're broadcasting it out on the watch
live football that's awesome really at
the best yes exactly and they got our
schedule up there and everything god
bless you Brad stop you know we're
coming as soon as we're legally allowed
to enter the state of Wisconsin late
game uh when will that actually kick off
by like 7:15 West Coast time I have
we've changed the time to 7:15 we'll see
when this game ends perfect singleterry
with the completion makes a lot of sense
at though two yards yeah I think there's
a chance we could see it come back here
so and of course you're gonna see Cam
Newton making his debut in the New
England Patriots Jersey squaring off
against the Tennessee Titans in New
England who gets first pick here Sean is
there do you feel caught do you care on
this one well I had Texan so I think I
get first pick for the next game right I
gave you oh that was in regards to the
Saints so I guess Cramer you're about to
be down three units once again I'll let
you pick no no you're gonna have a pick
I'll take the pick on the second game
tomorrow all right we're not going we're
not going tomorrow crying sorry you're
right choose them next Tuesday is the
next day we'll be streaming games sports
healing packets that complex ATSC for
all the info Allen out of the shotgun
play-action completes it underneath -
knocks wait can I cover my plus ten and
a half anyway - backdoor that Sean not
know someone Dre Dr Dre boy whatever
saying it's rigged Cramer wouldn't be a
shim without people yelling at it for
being rigged Dre day loves to talk about
how it's rigged all right let's see it
let's get some garbage Allen out of the
shotgun first and ten from the 47
dangerous throw and that's another
perfect ball a Roby had two
interceptions misery
yeah just trash hot trash Texans
second out over thirteen over twenty
three and a half for the second half
oh no wait did I not hit that because
they missed the oh my god I missed the
second half over
goddamnit I didn't realize that because
the bills didn't score any points jesus
christ
i play my losses much this is so
got it it was 14 to 10 yeah in the
second half Oh 23 was 23 and a half
wasn't it yeah god damn it
oh they just need to hit that extra
point I in my head I had already counted
it that's really bad but stay tuned for
the late game we're gonna see Cam Newton
and the new england patriots defensive
player of the game we like that with the
defensive touchdown that was huge
that was absolutely he already 3 to 14
is the final and Houston deshaun Watson
and the boys they're gonna wait around
and see what they get next whoa as the
fan Shawn what do you want to see
Houston verse well I like the storyline
of the New England led Cam Newton
Patriots but I think I'm gonna be on the
Tennessee Titans giving the Tennessee
Titans and the points against you Cramer
what is the what's the spread for this
next game so by saying you like
Tennessee that means they're gonna take
on like I'm saying I was asking you who
you think Houston is gonna take on who
do you want to see Houston face in the
next round is it is it Kansas City is it
Baltimore oh yeah that's right uh I like
I like a Houston Casey keep it real like
the real playoffs last year and for
those over on the the twitch feeds
periscope at one feed tonight we're not
disconnecting so we'll stay with you all
night long but we get to see Sean and
Colby no brakes oh we got the catheters
and we're ready anything any oh we got
to see the props
what were the big rods everyone went
through the price of those rushing on
TBT right 55 you know we are in it we're
pretty disrespectful to David Johnson
because he's uh that's a good day okay
he got going a little bit miss all you
but a good day Coates Colts oh three
baller yes the pets do have Cam Newton
updatable rosters oh yeah they do
oh man your your cooks prop that was
trash yeah
Kramer you nailed your prop I nailed it
early
yeah I wasn't proud Kooks led the game
in receptions call me trash I
quit you know what it is is I got a I
got introduces denta base maybe you're
right what is Pam's rating that's a good
question all right we can check we can
check after we get done showing the
stats here I got to imagine you
somewhere in the whatever beer you're
working with there knows beers Bay yeah
knows beers I'll take whatever and you
know we saw this a lot and Madden mayhem
a defensive player but above the game
for the the pick the pick 6 or a fumble
fumble pickup I guess yeah oh the bills
I mean that's fumble on the punt if they
had gotten that for a touchdown that
would have flipped that game thank you
bro
appreciate it all right that was a fun
game why not let a crazy wild plays and
especially fun if you're taking Ryan's
to units which I just did cuz I had a in
six and a shot loves to handle my units
all right what do we do next
long let's cue up the next game
Cramer get the get the lineup going and
we'll we'll talk about some of the
spread
I need my bookie Maddon it's an 80 cams
cams rating my bookie man let me know if
we're good to exit this game if all the
player props are calculated and graded
Madden 421 to know when the next games
starting the start time is 7:15 right
now that's assume if my bookie Madden
can tell us at that time works for them
that's when the game's gonna start
prunus and saying where's the claws at
boys we don't uh we don't have any white
claws in the studio I know Kramer's
dabbled with the shelter but I'm a I'm a
whiskey first guy occasionally getting a
little beer gone if I go for claws there
bear claws all right then credit chris
farley I used to grab bear claws toward
a time and give them lodged god bless
that man class I miss ya miss Chris
Farley he was funny rest in peace better
career when it's all said and done
mahomes or Lamar Jackson I'm going Patti
mahomes
I'll go home as much as Lamar Jackson
had an awesome season and look great
his just the the running quarterbacks
they just don't have longevity well Jeff
Blake remember he was on the show and he
told us that like you know you can get
away with some of this stuff in a
certain age but then once once you know
28 29 30 hits you got to be a master at
your mechanics but what matters yeah he
was talking about my home said he
wanted to get his hands on my home he's
got shitty footwork can you stay on
passing props for a little bit Kramer
yeah people you know people got some
action on these things we can do we can
do all of this and of course perfect
time head over to my bookie get involved
on the late game use that promo code TFT
and you get a sweet deposit bonus I
think it's 50% deposit bonus up to
$1,000 highly recommend deposit and
withdrawing with Bitcoin if you need to
figure that out just go to sports gaming
podcast comm search Bitcoin we connect
we can help you guys figure out how to
deposit and withdrawal play when you get
paid over at my pinky Daddy G promo code
TFT again we're not we're gonna cutting
out tonight will be here through what
were we saying 717 kickoff sounds about
right I just did what the big networks
like to do yeah 7:15 no good 717 I like
the way that rings
all right I got a piss all right shout
out to the chat I'm gonna stand while I
pee Cramer does not have his uh he's
gonna stay away pees doesn't have his
catheter that's gonna pay out because
after that coleslaw sandwich Tucker
there are heavy odds against that Kolby
what do you like in the what do you like
in the late game I'm excited to see cam
I mean look the page his defense has
been good in these things it's really
been holier instead of that have been
trashed we did a we did a bonus
simulation game last night or maybe it
was two nights ago they all kind of run
together right now but uh was he good no
he was he was pretty he was kind of
inaccurate I think he had ended up
throwing like three interceptions
against the Jaguars
well that's mention mania it was a crazy
game cuz the Jags were up 25 ten in New
England and then cam led them on a
pretty epic comeback coming back ties
the game 25 25 and then they end up
losing in overtime so it was a very
exciting game but his interceptions are
really definitely cost them Italia was
no no like amazing quarterback I mean
really Derek Henry's the the piece that
keeps that offense moving
I remember that them in Madden mayhem we
had them they took an early exit to the
Colts yeah and in Tennessee I think
they're they're a decent team they're
probably better in real life or at least
this has real life that they are in
these sins Reed and you know they
haven't really I don't think Henry's
rating really reflects it in and Tana
was kind of playing out of his mind I
knew it was more so he finally wasn't
being coached by Adam GaSe and they put
him in a good position but uh I mean but
even in the sims oh man that didn't
mince you we watched men should beat
Tandy who won Game two I think he came
down no overtime I think fournette had
like a 80 yard touchdown in that game
but I had not been truly took to
impressed with the Titans in this game
yeah Joey megamillions wanted to check
in on the score for the early game 3314
that was the final and bills are up 14
to 10 at half time and they got boat
raced in the second half classic bills
win
classic bills mafia well Kramer who you
want on this next one no should we can
we reveal that yet or we got to wait
yeah I'm on the other side of Shawn I'm
on Cam Newton feel like a new man all
right do we need to show anything else
little people want to see and you can
still bet on the the props for whoever
to win the football tournament so
there's the those future bets still
available my confidence pool is surely
dead I think I gave the bills of seven
yeah I thought I thought bills make a
little bit of a run - I definitely would
have picked them if had I got in first
choice
Titans right now plus three and a half
that's what we'll lock it in Kramer in
New England any thoughts on the total
total sitting at 46 I mean if I gotta
make a pick this Pats defense tends to
show up I don't know if if now is the
time to stand out on the Ryan Tannehill
is gonna show out island again it's
gonna come down to the defensive special
teams action I think if this gets over
if the gun to my head I'm leaning under
did what was the number 40 40 uh sorry I
looked at the wrong one there 46 is the
total so what's up because it opened at
44 and a half and what uh any sort of
prop bets either of you gentlemen like
I'm gonna start first
I'll go Cam Newton passing yards under
to 35 and a half oh you're going under I
see that's that's a bat you bet you want
to do another unit on that yeah I want
the over on that actually and then Sean
you want to do it you know I'm
rethinking that see look at this guy he
well cuz I remembered how I'm
remembering his performance last game in
got he was thrown at Lots the running
backs got some easy easy completions Cam
Newton passing touchdowns set it one and
a half on the interesting based on the
fact that they're still grading props
I'm gonna say maybe the start time is
gonna be closer to 7:20 okay
what do you think about Sony Michelle
rushing yard 64 and a half I believe it
hi it feels a lot hi yeah you know we
haven't seen a lot of the Titans
candidly we they got they were one and
done no no we saw them lose twice I love
the men she once okay yeah I was but
even those two games not memorable and
as I looked through this prop sheet I
mean I think one
yeah sure cam is a fun Beck is that
that's an awfully low passing total but
I think the area that I would really
look to attack is we see him he's shown
out in these games in a big way and
that's Mohamed Sanu
yeah yes play good yeah 57 and a half
yards that might be an area for me to
attack it seems like on the other side
of that coin Edelman seven receptions
are you kidding me that's high he's
never involved yeah and you're paying
for with the juice under 7-1 25 the last
little thing I'll throw out because of
the way the Patriots play defense Ryan
Tannehill over nine and a half rushing
yards is awfully intriguing I'm seen at
11 an hour
O's maybe it's just updated them you
might have a more updated number so what
did I just throw out but Sanu over 57
and a half
Edelman under now 6 and I moved the
market are you kidding me you're moving
move yours right in front or 7 take the
six-and-a-half receptions and then
Tannehill over nine and a half rushing
yards you know what I'm doing it Ryan
Tannehill passing touchdowns over one
and a half give that to me all day thank
you thank you
that's my lock for my prop cobia what
what prop do you like I'm actually
trying to locate them on the mobile app
right now because I'm having a hard time
but I can tell you that I would take the
Cam Newton in the over for what you
meant there you go to 30 to 35 and a
half 35 and a half now Wow
let me what else we lookin for some more
if you don't mind if you don't mind just
going through that what do you want what
you would give me a player anything
anything Derrick Henry rushing yards 88
and a half Sonne Michele rushing yards
64 and a half mmm I'd go under Michelle
I like that play
what about receptions today do they have
well and I like the Titans but Corey
Davis I would go under five and a half
receptions that seems way too high he
doesn't get involved that much Shana
just moved to for just one or plus 140
I'm if you're looking for the props Joey
Mega Millions is over on Twitch if you
just head over to the sims sport
simulation category and then choose
Madden NFL odds and choose Madden 20 sim
lines they were all right there
underneath the game if he's on mobile
maybe that's why he's are you having
trouble I was having a hard time finding
earlier today it was easy Colby Colby
also the danza base it needs an upgrade
yeah also yeah these are all things if
you see the player props you just have
to keep scrolling down there you think
you're going past the other game but
they're taking me to the player press ok
and make sure you give us a follow on
twitter instagram at sports gambling
podcast on instagram at gambling
podcasts on twitter recommend tweeting
about the big tournament hashtag at t ft
kramer we got to give away some free
play in this next all right I'm down
make it I think we just you know I think
we just freestyle shown all right let's
nice though so yeah stay tuned we'll be
giving away some $25 free plays during
the game during the during the action
which is about to kick off let us know
what your on they're still grading the
player props from the first game that's
what we're looking at right now stats
david johnson david johnson 74 rushing
yards so he actually had a decent game
for the amount of talk point to
precarious an amazing and he did fumble
so i mean compared to the I would take
that on the bills in a heartbeat
Bills had like 10 yards rushing I feel
like Kramer can we see Stefon Diggs
passing information there you go he had
himself a game 5-4 116 a lot of that was
that deep pass but they really couldn't
couldn't take enough advantage of it
yeah I mean Alan struggled the whole
game that offensive lying I killed I
think by the d-line and I couldn't even
run the ball
people people are still waiting to get
paid John and chats rage and people are
fired up
they want to see digs of stat line if
you can go to that pay attention Kolby I
already did that but I'll do it again
it's 5 4 1 16 that's a hell of a game
that is a great game it's a tough tough
losing effort well a lot of that was on
that one big play listen we are we're
waiting for management to tell us to
move on I'm I'm bulletproof right now
you can fire your your words at me I
dare you everyone wants to you know you
want the player props then we got to
grade the player props Cramer a lot of
people are wondering about the fit
between Cam Newton and Bill Belichick
will it work will it make sense yeah
it's doing a little digging they're very
strange people I think it's gonna work
clarkey they don't they don't work well
with the media two things they have in
common another thing it's doing a little
bit of research both both have destroyed
a tablet or laptop in their life Bill
Belichick of course smashed his
Microsoft Surface tablet where's this go
sideline and Cam Newton after he stole a
fellow students laptop in college threw
it out the window well he was at Florida
destroying the laptop so wait wait so he
stole it did it go home or did he just
like say hey dude and just dude out the
window that's unclear that's a power
play that is a I'm guessing he took it
from whoever he was stealing it from and
said like you and threw his laptop
it's my bookie Madden saying we are good
to move for I can appreciate that play
confirm we are good to move on to the
next game Norsemen 518 wanting to know
what I think about the first half totals
ah let me take a look here see what
we're cooking with I feel like if you're
playing first half total that totals
you're going under yeah generally these
games have started off alright we wrote
we're okay to move on to the next game
Sean like it it's all been put on to
tape there we go yeah
definitely go under first half these
games sendeth more score and a little
bit more it's going it's economic can't
I can't do it
Kim wasn't at Florida backed up Tebow
yeah he was the backup to Tim oh really
well they got kicked out for still a lot
how younger yeah you're not aware and
you call yourself a brazen Gator fan
come on yeah what's classic is at the
time Dan Mullen who's now my life is
Florida head coach he went to Urban
Meyer prior to the season starting and
being at their spring ball and saying
dude Cam Newton - way better than Tebow
and everywhere I was like I'm starting
Tebow we you know we've won this many
games with him I'm not putting in cam
over Tebow and I mean I was he wrong no
I mean Tim Tebow call me do we want to
mess with the elbow retro and all let's
go you know I know Shawn doesn't like
them but I vote for 80s
please bring those back is this what you
want to say I like the gray face mask
Oh
Grey's pretty good Colby wants the old
ones oh this is what you want right I
just don't like any of that mean to me
they went when they went like way over
that like that's that's where you want
total I said that's Tecmo Super Bowl
dude and if you go back to like the 70s
that that guy with the spiky or like
hiking the ball he was like had a
vicious face they changed the face over
the years because our society kept
getting soft shot but those uniforms in
general just hiking the ball it's great
what's our who are they playing the
Titans
can you go with oil errs can they do the
Oilers in this I don't know let's see I
mean those are bad I mean I just don't
like the sides that's horrible
that is horrible that's not bad I just
don't like the signs that's it they're
of one of the worst uniforms in the end
of hashtag times horrible yeah
that's not great there you go well I
like the white helmets then oh boy yeah
don't do that
I'm
be weird alright we're figuring out the
they don't let you do orders do they the
uniforms here the outfit shown now fits
they have a lot of options I'm pretty
important here we go what do we owe oh
that's beautiful right there man can't
they can't wear blue what do you mean if
the other helmets are white there we go
they have to yeah okay all right are we
good with the AFL anniversary away let's
do it let's get it going and by the way
Nick I'm stranger things all day well
talk about an out-of-context comedy
comment and of course we are accepting
the fact that we are not controlling
either one of these teams Sean let's no
let my Sims do their thing random
weather we are ready is everyone ready
does everyone have their nose beers
everyone got their bets in crack it open
let's do it Colby's got his shades on
are we on the same side again Colby I'm
on the patreon oh let's go yeah let's
get a $25 free play going for everyone
sitting through the the halftime pregame
show with a pregame what do we give them
show $25 free place sending a photo of
your setup for this room football
tournament best setup wins a $25 free
play over at my bookie daddy G promo
code TFT just send out a tweet hashtag a
TFT tag us at gambling podcast send out
a tweet Tagus at gambling podcasts on
twitter and best one will win a $25 free
play over my bookie Dynegy promo code
TFT best man win hell yeah Sean so let's
let's recap to unit bet what's the
closing line for last I saw was three
and a half okay so three and a half oh
maybe it's four hold on I was trying to
give you a call take Jesus Christ you
see this guy I wasn't logged in Cramer
yeah to be honest nothing's working on
my computer right now so we'll see and
then I think you know more lacking in it
for Sean what's the total right
give me the Patriots team total ooh okay
over over what is it it's 24 yeah that's
a high-scoring no it's not Kraemer gang
over 24 on the Pats over 24 for another
I like that I like that I'm gonna back
you on that again sending a photo of
your setup for the football tournament
hashtag of t of t at gambling podcasts
best setup wins a $25 free play over at
my bookie Todd AG big shout-out to all
things comedy let's do it Kramer let's
just I'm going all management said two
more minutes 7:25 official kick people
are people are just demanding their
money they want a lot of money on the
first game I guess
well you were the idiots over here me
and picked on D on the bills yeah what
were you guys thinking you addressed me
as a base that's right that was it I
agree that was it Oh
people management is in the crosshairs
Shawn there and there we are bulletproof
over here
[Music]
oh no what's happening the drones are
fire and left and right should be a good
game I mean you get to two decent AFC
teams of course Logan Ryan I think it
what had the interception the pick six
to end it in the real game yeah that's
isn't that great that that was the last
throw that Brady ever threw it a
Patriots uniform this is old fun little
nugget Ryan Tannehill of course played
receiver in college for a little bit and
then switched to quarterback Ryan
Tannehill planned on becoming an
orthopedic surgeon at football had
worked out for him pretty ambitious yeah
those are your two options either
professional football player or
orthopedic surgeon wasn't he unaware of
the teams that were in his division when
he entered the NFL or was it which to
which direction the Sun set well that
was jarred golf with the sunset but I
think Tannehill was unaware of the
division the division thank you for
reminding me
ex-dog Cramer gang has also got a unit
on over 230 not what was the cam 235
passing to man I mean we're just we're
selling everything dude oh well I also
threw out Tannehill over nine and a half
I also threw out who's the receiver Oh
Edelman under seven and what was the
last one so new over fifty seven and a
half yard didn't you take the run under
two no no no no run owners mmm all right
are we good management Kolby Stevie
Wonder dad I'm ready to get going I I
got Shawn two four six eight units when
it's on this game I'm going full DJ is
it okay if I I might have to bring out
the cushy dreams yeah you got it man is
that accepted because that's good luck
to men
let's get it going Kramer you dreamed up
we're good let's do it Richard Sherman
you remember him from the guy who
couldn't cover people in the Superbowl
wow talk about a systems type player oh
wow he played pretty well in San
Francisco still it's the same system
he's not on the level but you know how
you beat Richard Sherman
you take him over the top he's old he's
slow he went to that private school
Stanford and we're coming to you live
from Gillette Stadium this is the
football tournament presented by the
sports game line podcast my boogie-down
AG promo code TFT and ATC aka all things
comedy the Patriots led by Cameron
Newton will take over at their own 25
first and 10 honestly 23 yards right
there sinew getting involved early or so
that murky slick know he was the guy to
play in player props he wasn't either I
don't even think they had a player prob
Sean I will say we might have outdone
ourselves this could be the nicest
looking uniform combo we dreamer the
trip is off the charts massive amounts
of drip going on at Gillette Stadium
right now came out of the shotgun first
intense spin move come on it like get it
Marquis lay he's his guy his pass game
turn to 4:30 don't even run a running
clock let's go straight down the field
put it in the end zone
that's beautiful helmets and shout out
to Koch dog for trying to plug a tick
tock video in twitch you're blowing
people's mind doing on tick tock it's
just kids bro
Kim knew no the shotguns second and
three they're on the move here early
completes it underneath that's a first
right to the tight end the costs there
we go that's a first down for your New
England Patriots are using tick-tock
either you're a spy for the country of
China or you're into kids right well
that China is using that to steal your
facial recognition so enjoy helping
China once your data enters China
everyone has it Newton out of the
shotgun first and ten from the 42 they
hand it off
not much therefore James White's no need
to run the ball
they can't stop our passing attack only
picks up one second and nine Bill
Belichick the forty-one Bill Belichick
is looking just like he's been hanging
out of the beach a bit too much a little
maybe a little meth sprinkled in there
well a son is you know right there I
feel like that mullet man that mullet
he's probably like hey Dad try some of
this jam under center second and nine
checks it down underneath the Edelman
near the first down still times sending
a photo of your setup tweet it out tag
us at gambling podcast on Twitter and we
will pick a winner here shortly
better son Bruton or Belichick now do
scrutinies big character shout out the
deuce Gruden we need to get him on the
podcast dudes to rinse yoked out a
pre-workout terrible play handed off to
James White
picks up nothing loses one yeah fourth
and four and Patriots will they attempt
to 53 yarder here most likely
Yeah right they got the one of the best
kickers in the game yeah helmet it's
just so good detail on the helmet too
bad they don't have that kind of detail
in franchise mode see what I did there
Oh get people fired up oh it's blocked
damn it they block it pick it up do they
and he's oh my god they had a chance for
a scoop and we're not on the right side
of the special teams luck today :
Wow just why were they running the ball
there just throw the ball
Tannehill under Center hands it off to
the bees Derek Henry that guy you don't
want to let that guy get going if he
gets momentum he gets hot it's gonna be
a long day in New England just look at
Derek Henry hungry somebody had it yeah
[Applause]
somebody next odor line somebody had to
tweet like you know if they make jackass
three and one of the things isn't trying
to tackle Derek Henry what's the point
yeah
play action bite a nail and second an
inches come over them horrible start for
the player props on the Dan to base I
would still like in my Daniel over one
and a half passing touchdowns one could
be loading here I like this off what's
happening here I don't know someone's
that supposed to be a dick drone strike
yeah I hit the drone strike
someone's blowing up the chat Daniel out
of the shotgun bubble screams Davis
again
the tackle he's just hit he is already
over the props right well Kobe you may
get a break they may grade that as a
rush
no they agreed that as a pass oh man I
was hoping you'd get the pass there he's
had two catches for 42 yards I cannot
ever be addressed as the database first
and in Sam's on the pick Dundee I know I
know but it's a too late if the damage
is done
and this is not a good start for cam
dude no hado chamo down he goes I like
that that's fine the way he threw him to
the ground it was like it had a little
you behind it in the words of Chris
Berman Patrick Wang Chung oh wow
second a goal from the fourth that's
fine um I'll take the sack there sets up
another sets up a passing touchdown for
my man to Ryan Tannehill second they go
out the floor Tannehill under center
split eye back to throw hey check out
that crater and down he goes again Jesus
Christ third and goal
[Music]
[Applause]
hmm again still time give you a couple
more minutes sending a tweet of your
setup tag at gambling podcast Tannehill
out of the shotgun third and goal
fumble Shawn pump-fake has time
plenty of Tony intercepts throws of the
way out of the end zone I had a guy open
to I wouldn't like to see him fire that
big skin does he still have that really
hot wife or she left a bit I think
they're still together probably stayed
because they're not remain down the
country best-case scenario
Colby yeah we now do we pay back with a
block of our own I mean we should read
home I feel like we're the better
special teams it's up and it's good
Tennessee scores first out to a nice
three nothing lead here early in New
England chat to able underscore 631
congratulations it's got two screen
experience going with us and some Jim
Beam yeah he's got a a watching screen
and a bedding screen I haven't gone Jim
Beam in a long time but I shout out Old
Faithful down the drain a over in the
twitch chat for calling me trash nice
hey next time please include me in there
too I mean look sim God's not everyone's
gonna love you I'm cool with that
in 80/20 rule 80% of the world is stupid
grammar you still picked these awesome
uniform so how can you be trash outfits
please yeah alright this off-white grass
is fine Harold yeah the more I look at
it the more I love it straight fire
Tennessee off to a good start
and Tennessee scored first that was the
underdog and of course if you're new to
the stream or the podcast whenever we're
talking Patriots this is our favorite
sound drop it's a baby
one of the greatest viral I can delete
that that's gotta be it's also on and
and the Patriots just lost a third-round
pick because of only I gave two point oh
yeah the Patriots like look the Patriots
fans that feel like ESPN the NFL how are
out to get them are out of their minds
play action first and ten crap deep down
the sideline
craft is the guy that put good down
along remember when everyone thought
they hated each other hold on Colby let
me celebrate this Mohamed Sanu
with a big catch how many yards was that
tell me forty yards I'm the good ball
that's right thirty yards right there I
got over fifty seven and a half my props
are looking mint right the tires start
to your props Cramer new under center
first and 10 from the 43 hard count
hands off to Sony Michelle nothing there
for Michelle remember when everyone
thought they were like enemies and then
like the Rams had moved to LA it was the
first game in LA and they like pan to a
press box you can see craft and and
Goodell just sitting there like looks
like they both got a cocktail in hand
laughing telling John who's a count
Hasselhoff alright the coach of the
Tennessee Titans who's cutting that
guy's hair willing to cut off his dick
for a Super Bowl that was one of the
greatest quotes of all time
Newton completes the Dilla cost in
stride down to the 22 I am so on fire
right now I feel like it's the Super
Bowl I got all these props in my pocket
Sean Newton six for six he's off to a
great start the cut off the dick for a
Super Bowl angle is actually highly
underrated if you look at John Bob but
he became a porn star so you win a Super
Bowl then you go be a porn star call me
man under center first leg horse-trader
you doing back to throw completes a wide
open to the Titanic
let's go let's go
oh is that Kellen Winslow jr. is he
still a target hey this man he's money
let's go
alright so now Devin I see I see Wow now
been to that sushi spot well Tennessee
and it's good Tennessee not scoring a
touchdown is really gonna come back and
bite them in the ass am I glad I didn't
go after an under play and I just went
with the Patriots over 24 because I
didn't expect the Patriots the looks but
damn good
it only took a day a couple days of some
zoom meetings Cam Newton the PlayBook is
down they're stretching it out we saw
none of this the other night what we
called cam against Gardner Minshew and
the Jacksonville Jaguars he's a
different miss responding to the
criticism to the to all those WEEI radio
co-hosts calling him out for his
celebration saying he's not gonna fit in
New England it's coming out with an
emphatic great play first half shout-out
to brazen Gator fan I forgot how much we
pissed them off last last time we did
this Kolby need to piss you off man come
on the Titans don't really have fans
Kolby they're like an arena team that
somehow the NFL do you remember last
season Shaun and we challenged what the
when we challenged the Titans when
we predicted they would go 5 and 11 on
the NFL preview pod can rage all the
Titans fans were blowing up our mentions
and of course shown you would want to
subscribe to the podcast because we will
start breaking down everything you can
break down to the National Football
League starting soon because we know the
National Football League will play this
fall oh wow good to have you on board
Kramer hopefully Tannehill completes it
to the tight end
he looks shook their fingers
very fortunate to complete that pass
Jonah Smith with the catch picks up nine
second one at the 49 hashtag tighten up
dick gets Berger ask who's your favorite
Menendez brother
that's pretty hilarious oh wow it's a
time man it's Sophie's Choice I'm
missing this conversation how did that
just randomly pop off Tannehill under
center second one oh come on don't run
the goddamn bubble string Corey Davis
getting thirty touch your lifetime lucky
didn't catch that golden chunk
Colby's ability to find the off-the-wall
book chat comments is amazing they're
just flying by Tannehill under center
just hand it off to Derek Hanna this god
damn it play-action completes it let's
go this is gonna be a shootout I
did not expect this job well I did cuz I
had over one and a half passing
touchdowns for my boy Ryan Tannehill as
Kobe likes the callin by the way he's
already got one he's a wide receiver you
know there's not a real quarterback I
it's amazing to me surely no one else
out there in the universe doing Sims is
giving out player props no or playing
with updated rosters higher or giving
out random bonus play or giving out
$10,000 Curtis was coming after
something god god help his girlfriend as
helmets are amazing look at these
helmets man what are you guys talking
about those are amazing beautiful that's
why the Roughnecks were cool in the XFL
is they brought back that yeah it was a
good look I like how they did it they
did it for the city of Houston yeah
Tennessee out to a nice 10-7 lead here
early patriots drove down they responded
and responding great fashion Cam Newton
him starting this is the first time
since 1993 the Patriots have started a
quarterback they didn't draft
93 do you know who that quarterback was
that they served 19 1993 that they did
not draft
I'm gonna guess $25 free plate as the
first person who gets this Ryan d3 cuz I
don't guess Colby keep it in yours in
your home okay okay no Colby can guess I
just won't say if he's ready Rock well
the first thought but I think that was
more 92-91 was humility but I think
after that you go what like this is all
a Cordell ball stand elbow maybe or John
Freese started with them that was
probably Newton out of the shotgun hands
it off to James White's I think James
white could have a huge fantasy year
catching balls out of the back colby
don't overthink this one yeah it's easy
yeah Hawaiian built checking in YouTube
8 CC beers and NFL equals great time
Mahalo it's so much acted by the
Patriots Lou Bledsoe is not the correct
answer
Jared Stidham someone gets it $25 free
play Newton back to throw I'm under
center checks it down to Sony Michele
first down and then some this holler 42
this offense Shawn looks completely
different josh mcdaniels went into the
lab he came out Bill Belichick just
looks like he's got a stomach virus or
Scott Zola not correct answer the T was
Jackson angle it was drafted by the
Patriots LeBron James source that's you
attempt to control us q millon Tom
Hudson Jeff Carlson none of those
answers are right rip sports analytics
congratulations you got it correct Scott
succulence no man the old dolphin I
didn't even realize you realize told you
not so ever thank you :
I like that one that's a great trivia
question well that's why you're
listening to the oh let's go Pat's feels
dirty send me send me to my room Sean
[Laughter]
second and six hand it off to James
White I'm sorry Sony Michelle nothing
there
games not working maybe maybe we need a
little help from Joe Buck shout out to
Randy Moss this dude looks like Hitler
it's hilarious that they make him look
like that
shout out to Hawaii love the state of
Hawaii it's awesome get your shaved ice
yeah shave ice Sean please I'm sorry
shaving Holly Newton head of the shotgun
third and five deep hi to the outside
goes up and pulls it down and for
temperature first and ten at the 35 my
buddy who lives over in Hawaii and we
make fun of him he took us to get shrimp
tacos and or Justin shrimp in general I
don't think it was from tacos in Hawaii
yeah okay
shrimp he doesn't take the shell off the
shrimp it's the shrimp with the shell it
that's insane buddy just eat the shrimp
with the shell he's a grazing
hippopotamus you ever seen watermelons
enter a hippo's mouth it doesn't matter
what happened it cool says that's what
is the flavor is that you guys are crazy
it's gonna get all jammed up in your
throat yeah Newton under Center second
and 11 you're a sure I'm not a
Cramer you know that there's only
one person who dips in this studio and
it's not you it's not me you're right I
have been too kawaii I I had a Spencer
spent a day beautiful hikes ate
a lot ate lunch at the on the sleeping
giants chin that was pretty badass
definitely recommend that hike third and
11 new net of the shotgun oh how was
that possible incomplete pass for Newton
and it comes on a key third down forcing
a 53-yard field goal right let's say
I've already had one field goal block
let's block everybody
Dylan gear atthe checking in on the
YouTube ATC I hope cams actual first
game as a pat is as good as he's looking
in this sim
I mean if I was in well oh he must be
kicking in the city wind that hit the
eye and Patriots Wow no swagger over
them prude Austin saying I wonder if he
eats eggs the same way shell on yeah
that is just odd there's protein in the
show sir you know that I did your I love
me some protein my favorite source of
protein garance protein candy bar
no wait Kevin Danielle all day the
play-action completes it what kind of
dangerous throw over the hills throwing
some darts here though not the Tannehill
I'm getting our boy firk sir whoo-wee we
had some night we made some nice money
on him in the playoffs he was fun
imagine uh I guess that that that field
goal wouldn't have mattered because it
was New England minus 1/2
Tannehill under center they'll do it for
the first quarter over hits Tyson high
score in first quarter normally and I
feel bad I gave out first half under cuz
normally it starts it starts much slower
scoring wise and I would imagine if we
head over to my bookie dot AG and we
loaded up Sean Tannehill hands it off to
Derrick Henry he was good enough kick
them not much there and we pull up these
odds all right well I got to imagine
there's gonna be an opportunity to take
the under here 54 and a half is the
number Shawn we've moved a whole
touchdown up is this gonna continue
feels a little high score and we'll see
though I haven't seen the same defense
we normally see at this Patriots a green
either teams playing much defense tan al
under center second and 10 at the New
England 40 back to throw danger
throw nearly picked off that's the tanne
hill I know I was gonna say just like
that just like that the live number over
at my bookie AG remember use that promo
code TFT Titans plus two and a half plus
100 on the money line Patriots minus one
forty five fifty one-and-a-half is now
the total Sean we mentioned the under
fifty four and a half in the line moves
over loaded right here
third and ten it's gonna fumble he's got
a fumble and demo goes huge sack forces
them out of maybe they were in long
field goal range
no I I mean probably one that would have
been a 57-yard er but if they have the
wind at their back the wind again if
you're new to these the wind can really
wreak havoc on something Maddon bring
the wind arrow back you have plenty of
real estate up there yeah guys gotta
know the wind we got money on this thing
and you know what that is man that's a
result of too many domes out there these
days no I mean is that what it is it is
because back in the days when everyone
played outdoors you had win was a real
element of the game of football and they
keep doing this if you get
these retractable roofs the only way the
only time we've seen wind in this game
is before the overtime kickoff
alright the lines move to three now Sean
Patriots - three - 175
Tim added that shotgun hands it off to
James White picks up a couple tough
running I'm telling you we're gonna look
back in this second and eight this game
is going under does feel like things are
tightening up a little bit I like what
you did there see what I did yeah that's
check time now he definitely looks like
a count I think we went Hasselhoff
because he looks German second and eight
came out of the shotgun handed off again
every guy's whole break them and James
White gets the first down end of the 32
did any either one of you guys get
involved in the run running props for
either a team I'm just on Tannehill
passing touchdowns over one and a half I
have Tannehill over nine and a half
rushing air that's why
I've flirted with the Michelle under
yeah III once flirted under Michelle to
Newton Oh dangerous throw forcing it to
the tight end Lacoste its knocked down I
got old man I mean so Pat's win this
game they are playing Kansas City in
Kansas City Titans win this game they
are playing the Ravens in Baltimore oh
just what they want if you're the
Baltimore Ravens do you want to see who
do you want to see Texans Titans well
they got their ass kicked by the Titans
in their actual daily show weights in
the Lacoste near midfield
the cost who was a guy had no idea who
he was before we started watching these
guys deep on the roster will say he was
one of those metrics likes him a tight
end shot big dripper want to know if
we're doing the other game the Steelers
box game no absolutely not
the next game we games we will be doing
is gonna be the NFC wild-card on Tuesday
July 7th
hands it off the Sony Michelle nothing
there door goth bottom wipe checking in
on the YouTube ATC Patriots are gonna
lose this game yeah well they're down
seven three three sorry down three ten
to seven III don't know I mean cams
doing a decent job driving I'm just
worried this is a different offer I
think the Patriots have to worry about
their defense more than the office there
we go they're great throat
I don't know if I was right about the
Edelman under prop we've not seen his
involvement like this typical well that
first game we saw a couple nights ago
Kramer cam looked horrible three
interceptions just look and now maybe he
shook the rust off after what a year and
a half not playing now he's finally
getting some momentum feeling
comfortable in New England getting
familiar with the system
[Applause]
play action might noon out of the
shotgun first and ten deep all to the
side guys
I just go over your master I might have
just cash are you kidding me we cash in
over prop on two catches show me the
stat then Newton already has 201 passing
yards too busy catches coaching I'm
circling on the sheet Sean that's one
unit the Kramer gang we're starting to
stand up yeah Newton over to 35 and a
half good thing he talked me out of that
Kramer checks it down the so Neela shell
hit me and Coulier on the over together
I mean good thing you talked me out of
taking me under shout out to Joey
megamillions he's gonna send me a dick
pic cool man I was a big Brett Favre guy
too long not all heroes wear capes
18 to 29 sup SGP been a while love the
confidence pick tourney style thank you
Paul complete is a new
did I nail that Mohamed Sanu I mean are
you kidding me we're giving people
winners are you kidding me player props
on a video game
what have we created what did we do we
created friends done this could destroy
real sport this could destroy real
football show who needs it
well we all do New England up 14 to 10
here in the second quarter 926 left to
go Mary oh York checking in apologies if
I mispronounce n I wonder if the
programmers who coded this game bet on
it well you know maybe that's maybe
that's next level we got to find
actually who's involved in that and get
some inside sources I got a couple guys
inside the building really I do
just great uniforms I mean if you're a
Pats fan you got to be happy the way
Newton's looking ok yeah I mean I think
what I'm worried about is that we're
gonna see some regression happen because
he did not look anywhere near this in
the game we called a couple nights ago
he's had a couple dangerous throws so I
do think there will be a Newton
interception in this game that I'm
predicting I think the big issue will be
where will that interception happen what
you know will they be able to get points
off of it because you know he's gonna
throw a pick at some point I think both
quarterback he's had some dangerous
throws already and the game seems to tip
its hand where a guy will have a couple
dangerous throws before throwing that
actual interception yeah Sean I mean
honestly the number one thing I'm
looking forward to do
for this quarantine enza's go to Hawaii
tail under center first and ten from the
22 back to throat check sit down
my jaanu Smith what are you gonna go cuz
I sent that an invoice for you guys to
fly me to a well there fly me to the
great the Maui Invitational have to
figure something out but there's nothing
better than just equalizing with the
universe from the edge of the edge of
the world I also I think I Oh
June Jones lunch so you know and he said
he offered golf so I can represent I've
been I've been hitting bombs like Phil
Mickelson lately on the on the on the
old links you hit the golf I'll hit the
Mai Tai's
takes another sack Kobe I feel good
about this one I feel good about this
when cam looks great I think can't Cam
Newton winning the Super Bowl this thing
would be the greatest thing ever oh man
that would be that's gonna be moving the
numbers out in Vegas I mean Sean if
there's one thing we've learned about
when we get on the mic these games get
interesting they do get exciting we saw
two overtime games last night Tannehill
yes and he's just taking sack after sack
I don't know what the hell he's doing
that offensive line falling apart well
when you're a wide receiver playing
quarterback you don't really know what
you're doing you don't know how to maybe
pencil on and shout out to Matt 4:20
saying he's got a golf hook up for us i
I'm looking at my golf bag right now in
Poipu Bay's the last course I played
over there or so and now Tennessee
forced a punt oh god this is gonna take
over 138 ohh
that is a massive punt return for this
game
Edelman Wow whatever's clever chicken in
people are actually betting on a video
game yeah right we are oh yeah
what else is there to bet on it's fun
it's entertaining any it live wagering
if you're just checking in go to my
bookie dad AG TFT you can get in in the
middle of the game Colby has been
hanging out with Bill Polian can you cue
the disgusting act use that promo code
TFT and right now you could bet on the
Titans plus 225 Shaun no way now write
only down four that's exactly where we
expect them to be there's a there's a
lot of value plus to 24 you could take
Titans Plus eight and a half a much
bigger spread than where we started at
four and a half or three and a half even
came back to throw out of the shotgun
first second and 10 but Cam Edelman
getting involved early and often I
didn't see this coming yeah that I think
that's gonna be a loser for me do you
put out a spread for fourth of July
creamer
what do you mean like do you do like you
know people over at the house you get Oh
what would I typically be doing it
Dodger game Wow well if they do they do
awesome fireworks after the game so we
we typically would that's that's our
fourth of July tradition last three
years okay
Newton out of the shotgun third one
hands it off to James White I mean look
he ran down to the five the kids want to
see fireworks the worst thing in the
world is getting somewhere super early
to watch fireworks did you sit there
friend so why not gets there somewhere
super early and watch the gauge ball
game and watch fireworks the fireworks
are legit too yeah I seriously legit
they let you go on the field it's dope I
used to date a girl whose uncle was the
Spanish announcer for the Dodgers
although Newton back throw
dangerous throw I mean that was an
amazing hookup but I probably should
have stayed with her just for that
second and goal at the 5 Cam Newton's
shoulders looking great and shout out to
everyone that lives in states that
aren't uptight let you shoot off
fireworks although you know it's funny
is when you see those tweets from the
law enforcement look at the fireworks
works we took off the street it's like
what you got better things to do bro
dude go to East LA the Kid neighborhoods
Oh news out of the shotgun second ago
from the bottom completes it to margies
lead just join it I hate it one yard
away and right now it's the whole city
of Los Angeles its fireworks every night
East LA on 4th of July is literally the
whole war zone there's a spot up near
where I live where you can see most of
LA and on 4th of July like late at night
it's pretty cool because you just see
fireworks everywhere now third and goal
from the one big third down compared to
its quarterback sneak cam under shacket
not it undersell handsy Weiss into the
end zone easy money baby earn karma
checking in on the YouTube ATC I wasn't
sure if people are betting straight
money or another type of currency
credits a sports bet a lot so this could
fill a temporary void now you're talking
well are there a max bet such a cap yeah
I think eventually they'll limit you at
at some point but they barely get a few
hundred n I don't know what the exact
number is well show the futures had
thousand dollar limits on them I believe
so I'm sure yeah and they're taking
thousand dollar bets on few step one
head over to my bookie dot hey Jay use
that promo code TFT and then yeah right
now the live line Titans plus ten and a
half plus four hundred on the money line
Patriots mine - 900 listen they take
Bitcoin that's all you need to hear if
this guy's a serious sports gambler or
investor as I like to say and he's not
using Bitcoin he's full of if he is
using Bitcoin my book he takes Bitcoin
and that's all you need to hear because
that's the way to go that's the way to
go yep
I'm advertising this is Bitcoin deposit
and withdrawal for Bitcoin what is
Bitcoin paying it's not enough zero and
New England's offense coming out firing
I just love decentralized the you know
things that cryptocurrency and check out
the villain Bert podcast they got into a
crypto and their last episode check that
out obviously if you're on the YouTube
ATC I'm sure you're probably already on
it but for those of you who aren't check
out that bill burr Bert Kreischer
podcast that one is a fun one hilarious
dudes very hilarious dudes shout out to
OSU 57 says he's watching this at major
league at the same time check out my hat
Major League you have no oh yeah that's
a great hat Tannehill under center first
and ten from the 25 best line of that
movie I've said this before but
behringer goes to like his old
girlfriends fiance's house and he just
randomly shows up there and you know
after like a beer I think he leaves and
the guy goes to tell him like hey get
the away from her and he goes suck
my dick like it's just a great delivery
of Tom Berenger yeah the Humphreys with
the zero yard jet sweep second of ten
and if you're a Tennessee fan you want
to see Henry get in the ball a little
bit more yeah what are they doing and
there he goes
ain't gonna work their offensive lines
getting destroyed better check those how
to shut down Henry only has three rushes
like why are you running jets jet a jet
sweep - who was it Adam Humphries come
on come on I'm like a Belichick it's
Grady for this he is ready man he's been
working out he's got that job he's ready
to go down the Caribbean and start the
crushing Daniel back to throw 39
completes a bullet pass for a first down
they needed it the Titans offense it
kind of going cold they need a first
down to stay out on the field they need
some more points before laughs yeah and
the way this game script is perfect for
my Ryan Tannehill to go over nine and a
half rushing yards I'm waiting for it
he's gonna pull it down and run
these times of course former wide
reciever shown I know I know you know
that but maybe everyone out there didn't
know Ryan Tannehill actually a receiver
Tanna uh-uh sorry Henry takes up one
Tannehill actually play it played
receiver Lamar Jackson was just asked
the play receiver there you go big
delineation oh man look at that hair he
looks like a tit 13-year old yeah that
this the gray hair on the side not
looking good for that bag ramble but the
flow be oh yeah the flow be yeah those
things are probably flying off the Davis
Corey Davis breaks a tackle and he could
bet against him and he's a sim gun
Cramer now we've hit two player props in
the first half my Ryan Tannehill over
one and a half passing touchdowns
already hit wow that was a busted play
with Tackett Corey Davis under I did and
this guy's destroy his wondering why he
was playing so well this games going was
awesome I am in New England over 24 team
total Sean coaching Blackwater I hit
that in the first half Tennessee team
total was only 22 so any any over
betters are just licking their chops
right now in this game how about that
move by me to avoid taking the under eye
I had a gut thought it might be an under
I avoided it swung the other way took
the over Sean the updated numbers over
in my bookie AG promo code t ft six and
a half for the Pats - 900 + 400 for the
Titans 56 and a half is the total yeah
well I don't know what it is as soon as
we hop on these Sims Cramer the games
just get more exciting I again Cam
Newton looked nothing like this in the
games we've called the four Tannehill I
don't think I've ever seen him be this
efficient we've never seen Corey Davis
do a goddamn thing
no
do you believe in miracles hasn't caught
more than three passes in the game since
his days pj fleck at western michigan
row the boat New England with the return
and looks Oh beautiful beautiful
speaking of Hawaii and now New England
will take over at their own forty eight
three timeouts left to 26 left to go
certainly they got a chance to score
here before the end of the first half
this game might go over oh my god I mean
what was the before the first happens
the total is what 44 yeah came out of
the shotgun first and 10 back from
plenty of time deep down to the
sidelines oh goes up for a can't hang on
hashtag tighten up let's go Titans mmm
get it going that's the right read that
I think 101 coverage who gets the ball
at half I'm pretty sure the Titans
correct pretty sure yeah no the Titans
do because remember the Patriots went
down the field and had the kick block
Newton out of the shotgun again across
the middle sinew so know who's gonna
have them I told you pregame he would
have a huge game I wish I could have
made this a fire bet
goddamn this this is he's a four 497
already in the first half and Kim noon I
think is over his passing is he's got
over 240 or 230 feels like 235 and a
half Ching I mean land on under is
heating up you know my book you may not
offer these player props anymore if we
keep handing out winners like this guy's
[Applause]
business I can't help myself
I'm sure they'll figure out a way to
deal with it came out of the shotgun
first and ten from the 28th back to
throw oh and that was almost the
interception a little bit of the body
bump they're supposed to like the
National Football League I know but I
just want to win money I've been i've
been losing on this damn wide receiver
his Kobe's a real for saying that
I know empty said I get it I deserved
the crimson out of the shotgun the
second and ten back to throw spin oh and
they got the pressure on down he goes
that's huge because this is they're
right on the edge of field goal range
we'll see New England has missed two
field goals alright a last kick was like
way Sherpa this is going the other way I
don't know if that was a wind thing or
the the Patriots kickers just sucking
big third down here 1:30 left to go
clock continuous around third and 16
from the 34 ski like five oh they got to
get one of these interceptions it's it's
crazy because cams have been like
throwing darts but he's also had like
two or three balls that should have been
intercept alright we need to reach
Center ourselves and focus we probably
just need to go to the half camp 51
yarder right here this is what I was
worried about it he's got him he's got
he's the best kicker in the game 51 yard
are from the left hand or chance he
misses it's up and it's no good
Oh for thriller you jinx the out of
that one was that my bad
I need bourbon this is do we do
we need a little repo
No your ear good phone yeah friends
don't let friends binge drink on a few
is this a Tuesday what day is Hell under
center first and ten from the 41 back to
throw
check sit down underneath is that Corey
Davis again no that is a Johnny Smith
yeah picks up six and the Titans have
three timeouts
near midfield I don't know what they're
doing sitting around let's get it going
boys oh and then they use their timeout
see this is oh yeah Jess if you're if
this is your first time watching these
band Sims the clock management just
makes you wanna it's sometimes
frustrating oh man oh well I will say
this mmm exciting start to wildcard
weekend the bills totally build deshaun
Watson will be in the second round and
you Joel at the middle for Derrick Henry
first down in a New England territory
they used the timeout lose lose their
kicker again he's probably he's gotta be
better than this Frank Joseph
Gostkowski as they say Shawn Rock I mean
look at Belichick he's just he's ready
for the he's ready for the world he got
the time machine
shut up to hawaiian built these guys are
great comedians got me watching these
simulated from the beginning of
good stuff thank you sir
throw us a thumbs up in the youtube uh
ATC channel
I just appreciate that make it look good
smash that like button everyone's
wanting to know where the hoodie is he
is uh he doesn't sign off on the unlike
giving his name or whatever he I think
he's like not in the coat on
where the hoodie is sports gambling
podcast.com slash merch there you go get
you a real hoodie
Tannehill out of the shotgun second
intent step yeah throw it he does checks
it down to zero to move Derrick Harry
doesn't get tackled like that he never
know but he doesn't really catch the
ball out of the backfield much either
she like video of him running Hills oh
my god she's a beast you did not
want to have to tackle that guy sounds
horrible dude I'd retire from
attack yeah yeah after that 47-yard
field alright yeah Tannehill out of the
shotgun third and three deep over the
middle the Davis of course and they have
one timeout left using shape the field
goal Corey Davis is gonna have the
greatest game in the history of his
career he's gonna beat flipper Anderson
single guys gotta leave this up what's
he got give me this that line for for
128 holy huh call me this game
your powers are strong yeah yeah
they're I mean the Kochs thing was
pretty interesting but Jesus this is
just insulting it's insulting Tannehill
out of the shotgun first and 10 from the
15 spin move completes it what are you
doing only is that they should have
kicked the field well now this is what I
talk about where the game drives you
crazy
Derek Henry career career best is 161
Corey Davis 161 on nine catches pause it
that was in the preseason right of
course Tennessee will start with the
ball second half oh my god so annoying
it was let's it's tough to complain
because Patriots are 104 three and
therefore Davis career-best nine catches
on 15 targets for 161 and a touchdown
against the Philadelphia Eagles 15
targets
I remember that Corey Davis game that's
son-of-a-bitch we're seeing the
second-best game right now
dude that coach needs to be fired for
having 15 targets at all that's got to
get fired are you kidding me there we go
look at that time of possession
Titans are Titans are on I would say a
little bit unlucky to not be leading
this game right
well they blocked a kick almost
recovered it took it to the house that's
probably that was I was pretty unlucky
not getting that done Wow Cam Newton
already cat I didn't Circle that way
play it one bit
cash register please well and while
we're here check out Ryan Tannehill
passing touchdowns over one and a half
touching what else what else did we bet
on Sean we have to check in on those are
the only props I get two rushing props
not much going on here well I didn't I
didn't actually bet it but I did say
Michelle Michelle I was gonna bet that
well edelman four catches that's not
good oh well his total was seven though
so there's still time to new is 40 yards
clear of his total coaching we nailed
that together Cramer gang oh there's
your guy
Burke sir he's got a cat Sean what did
he have a player prop did you get
involved in the mouth I work I would
have taken an over on whatever firk sir
he's his Blair Pratt probably would have
been a half catch I mean that's what he
was in those playoff games any defensive
props guys drew alien two goes they have
player props yeah no they do they got it
all four player stats
yeah exactly so my bookie dad AG promo
code TF t get involved
our next Slater games will be July 7th
where we see the NFC wild card games
from 2019 and real quick Sean I have
those games in front of me let's hear
the lines bet on those right now over at
my bookie dot AG the first game five
o'clock on the west coast eight o'clock
on the East Coast the Vikings head to
New Orleans where they're taking on the
Saints the Saints are minus six and a
half minus 350 on the money line Vikings
plus 250 and a half is the total boy
you're gonna have the Saints in that one
shy I stupidly took the bills you're
gonna have the same symbol of gods
I have Kirk Cousins in prime time that's
not good and then we have the C Seahawks
oh boy Sean Seahawks they had to
Philadelphia to take on your Eagles and
for some reason the most disrespectful
thing I've ever seen
since trying to convince America that
Mark Wahlberg could play football in
those oversized
pads he was wearing the Seahawks are -
four and a half - how you disrespect the
great name of Vince Papale Eagles plus
40 years old making an NFL roster forty
eight and a half is the total I mean
look Seahawks
I told you of Russell Wilson I gave I
assigned 12 points to my to my Seattle
Seahawks Sean I just don't know we
haven't seen Carson Wentz do a goddamn
thing
shout out to that Wichita guy on Twitter
who just keeps posting about Carson
Wentz I love it keep doing it how doing
the Lord's work some of his memes have
been good I'll give him that
everyone have been really to every time
I see him post I think of Matt Damon in
Good Will Hunting slamming the number on
the window and saying how how do you
like them apples
those apples are delicious one where
Carson Wentz is like doing a split in
front of the washing machine that one
did crack John what what did you want to
get should we talk second half yeah and
here ticularly the second half lines let
me refresh make sure I have the most
up-to-date yes and in the the football
tournament did start tonight we have we
have games again July 7th the wild-card
round for the NFC the second half line
for the Titans Patriots the Patriots -
two and a half shown Wow that's it
adjusted six and a half - 175 on the
second half money line plus 125 for the
Titans 23 and a half is the total team
total for the Titans ten and a half
Patriots 13 Colby's doing some
gymnastics well I think
Titans team totals 10 and a half you say
yeah I think they're figuring out their
offense and yeah I like the over
Tennessee ten and a half they can put up
11 points you couldn't be come on people
wondering if the player props are just
for these games I think so I think this
is a special test who don't we can't
speak for the good folks oh my bookie -
head over if you want player props and
you want to see him all the time you
should head over to twitch go to the my
bookie Madden page and let him know and
while you're there you should head over
a sport - twitch.tv slash sports
gambling podcast
because we're gonna be doing all sorts
of stupid on that channel Colby's
definitely gonna be playing old-ass
video games alright Sean so your play
for the second half is over ten and a
half on the Titans confirm yes lock that
in I already have Patriots team total
over twenty four that's a bit of a lock
but I do have to give something out to
the people for the second half what else
he thrown out I like what I'm seeing
from cam so I would I would double down
- two and a half you want to double down
I'll give my adjusted six-and-a-half
you're up three units want to do an
additional one unit so yeah
so I'll either have three or zero I'll
give you a 6 or 0 so it's an adjust well
six and a half for the game
alright one unit on six-and-a-half two
units on +4 I'm feeling good I'm feeling
good about this Tennessee team they get
the ball in the second half
they're gonna take care of business
alright management let us know when
you're ready Shawn yes we we I don't
think we've mentioned you know maybe we
mentioned it but we should tout a little
bit the jerry glanville episode we
dropped earlier this week yes make sure
you subscribe to the podcast at it--
said of just but banging story after
banging story know everything he says is
just a an amazing line the man loses cat
charisma the man news is just he's
touched every way he's crossed paths
with so many people loved the man check
it out you head over to Apple podcast
Spotify stitcher wherever you listen I
didn't know Cramer for for a cannon
really we are ready for the second half
hmm so let's see some emojis over in the
twitch chat let's get them firing away
let's get things off Sean Sean and I we
we went a little bit extra we now have
an additional unit Patriots - six and a
half is the bet for me I'm feeling I'm
feeling generous shown are you ready
Danny Hills due for a pick six hey I
love how you call him tanio so
disrespect it's not a quart of soda
look he got freezing he got the Sanchez
AFC championship yes
anyway shout out to the sim gods for
making these uniforms happen Titans with
a bit of her turn no honey's gonna break
it there take over first and ten from
the 25 Tennessee let's do it baby come
on
hashtag tighten up smash that like
button I've been watching YouTube with
my with the kids learn about what these
these casters do YouTube twitch YouTube
all the all the internet TV places
Tannehill out of the shotgun
first and ten completes it underneath he
could fumble near a first down that's
Adam Humphries flexing on him he's got
he's got decent arm talent for a little
guy Shawn you could appreciate little
guy arms right I'm throwing up plates
yeah I mean that's probably how I'd look
as a receiver rip this catches
everything over the middle if you're a
receiver you'd be well you're four three
guy yeah maybe for for a more heart
hustle and grit Tannehill rolls out they
pick up the first down is that Burke sir
that's our boy FERC sir oh let's talking
some we gotta love that if you're a
Titan backers first down let's go baby
ward
firk sir that doesn't sound as good yeah
what was that guy's name again fall a
farthing huh bobbing hand tan Oh
under center I formation person 10 from
their own 37 play-action interception
right here this is the one bullet passed
across the middle
had a guy open in my bookie Madden
pointing out or noting that player props
might be coming soon to every game but
for now definitely for the football
tournament promo code TFT net will be
back on the mics July 7th that's a
Tuesday night
ten'll under center back to throw second
and 10 so I'm gonna want dude dicks
nice ball by tani Hill 20 passes already
272 yards he's over his passing total
Brown with the catch rookie yeah yeah
great could have another big one never
good for the book when all the overs are
flowing in nothing is going on during
this game tan L under center first and
10 at 39 Henry the lone sit back showing
some blitz here see fish stick to it
Patriots love the box delay it games
come on Tom mother you're making Ryan's
look stupid everywhere friend of the
program Scotland saying Sean is a 4/7
special teamer slash gritty slot guy oh
nice I like that breaks down Bowser what
am i I'm sure he's gonna say like an
all-state quarterback you're a kicker
you're Ben Roethlisberger 10 L under
center first and 15 Derek Henry can just
he can't do anything right now because
don't get it going
what's classic Belichick he'll take out
your best player make him an on element
in the game non-factor I should say not
not an element but I'm drinking if
you're the Chiefs you're obviously
rooting for the Titans right you want to
see the Texans come to your house yeah
Tannehill under center second and 15 jet
sweep no play-action they hand it off to
then there you go there's Derek Henry
there's my man from Alabama and that's
why you keep feeding Derek Henry look at
Derek Henry that man is hungry he's
hungry for footballs you gotta feed and
get the bib out this guy needs to eat I
was hoping for a third and one or third
and inches but it's third and 2 which
means you're probably gonna get this
let's do it 32 at the 31 huge third down
here for the Titans Bowl
[Applause]
the only way of bubble screen works is
if Colby bets against that guy in higher
props we've figured it out
look at that Jew hate everything I mean
in the best parties from Central
Michigan like he said he's a I'm sorry
Westerman he said mid-major guy like
cozy
oh man well it's always good to go back
to the same world dude that's like 30
catches sick everything oh man
all right second and ten and Tennessee I
mean come on let's go d luck same
Colby can you pick player props for
every game it's all custom done done hey
but I did hit on a Newton over your
right I did I did introduce you as the
database instead of your true nickname
pick dundie sort of does that's the hex
man that's why the Patriots will
probably find a way to lose this game
rank grammar and shout out to mark in
the ATC YouTube chat who are the xxx
douchebags that thumbs down these guys
great question
welcome to the family they probably
don't like sports or gambling or
degeneracy or anything cool in life
Tannehill oh the best throw of the day
that lot of throw 300 yards
across his body they tell you not to
make that throw Dennis of John Elway
throw right there that's a dime to ever
Humphreys keeps his feet it's the ground
dude challenge that shadow to Hawaiian
built the YouTube ATC chat friend of the
program new friend of the program
completes a bird touchdown let's go
Tennessee match tag tighten up I'm on a
VJ Brown alright
as well that is awesome
now Tennessee about to take a
three-point lead he is a strong
representation of Ryan's true Allen the
second st. John Elway overrated Elma oh
no that's a Chiefs fan oh no John Elway
throw does that mean it was a loss of
the Super Bowl oh come on guys don't do
this we don't want to be on there for 25
minutes whether or not Janelle is the
greatest quarterback of all time but you
know who the greatest content providers
are all things comedy YouTube channel
the best online sports book my bookie
dad AG promo code t ft and the best
audience you hashtag dead dudes only the
good news John we we borrowed uncle dree
uncle Rico's Time Machine and we have it
strapped to Colby right now just in case
you want to talk Elway for 25 minutes my
arguments you know man
oh here we go all right what do we look
at Colby we need some work I feel like
you were getting a little confident he
was he was getting cocky
Colby is great at a reverse at jianxing
winning bets on his sins introduced his
dad to base I knew I was well
that's why I knew you were gonna be on
the opposite side so I needed I needed
to get my mojo back by throwing a
co-lead an out instead of pick gonna be
dropping the Dan to base I know how to
work a mojo I'm just here to look at
these beautiful as you beautiful Manny
I'm basically paying money to see these
beautiful uniforms hey I paid for worse
[Laughter]
[Applause]
noon out of the shotgun completes it
underneath to Marquis Lee one time I
went to uh I went to go see like I think
it was the recruit or the sold out so I
was like I was just gonna go random
movie and I signed it on a boat trip
that was it that was a mistake
second in one you wanted to talk about a
pain for things you shouldn't have I
will get to it in just a second after
the display second it was a Tijuana well
we could go there but I was gonna go
Atlantic City seller vibes
almost pulls it down some you I want to
hear your Atlantic City Wow I mean we're
underage and my buddy we get into a cab
and my buddy goes to the cab driver take
us to the dirtiest filthiest strip club
in Atlantic City the guy doesn't even
hesitate he throws it and drive and peel
out and it was he's like my brother's
strip club yeah she had one of the items
of clothing she took out was there like
she was wearing a high school
Letterman's jacket nice okay so my
oldest brother had his bachelor party in
Atlantic City like it like I don't know
what he was thinking but we go there and
like my cousins like hey let's get some
strippers and he just tries to make some
deal like some idiot on the street and
next thing you know like he strippers
show up and that one of them goes okay
she strips for like a liberty looks like
trash she looks like a homeless major in
Atlantic City
ice cream Jim Newton England boy he was
open and she's like okay who wants
with like three teeth showing
[Laughter]
New Jersey Linux city was not the kind
of place you'd go to celebrate yeah
beautiful well now I basically had like
Marion Barry with the wig on asking me
if I wanted a like under Center
play-action second and ten
and and Newton get a little cold here in
the second half this is what I was
worried about
we've lost the heat that he had going
early that's just the database hex God
dude your powers are strong I remember I
was in Atlantic City morning after and
it was like we were in McDonald's trying
to get breakfast and some someone's in
there trying to sell a Monopoly board
for three hours
that's like tales from the board and ten
completes into sinew and sinew having
himself a game yeah I called it I am I'm
the player prop guide Colby is the mush
mush Dundee my goodness that was a
Dundee you can't it's not fair to give
Dundee that type of negative criticism
Edelman he's not really involved in the
game munch he's got four catches on but
with the viperox going back to her
Newton play-action rolls out to his
right and he looks my god and there it's
be the devil there he is Julie Donovan
so the Cam Newton of old would probably
would have ran that ball but instead he
stays in the pocket hangs in there
completes the ball downfield dangerous
throw but the Patriots are inside the
red zone once again they're on the move
Newton under Center first and ten from
the 15 Wow Sonia Michele picks up ten
[Applause]
seven carries 12 yards one touchdown
that's a Mike Alstott line if I've ever
seen one oh my God look at him his eyes
are like crossed too they really did not
put effort into any part of this game
that perhaps they hate him second inches
from the five Newton out of the shotgun
big play here and he's got it
besides James white an inches Ryan
worked the Kramer gangs about to hit a
two-unit bet on the Patriots over 24
maybe I Jenks it maybe I done took that
as well so I'm you know don't celebrate
yet make sure to check us out in the you
tube the all things comedy youtube throw
us a chat in there throws the thumbs up
subscribe to their channel newton
understand ur hands it off and they
bring them the Blitz didn't block
anybody to got beat on all account what
was that play hi that was like punt
block yeah that's what you get really
pissed off the mat and just start
calling punt block till they figure than
age eight that was the play yeah
bringing the house second and goal from
the five I formation Newton under Center
surveys the field hands it off to the
fullback and who is hello check loves
that you remember dick fight L with the
run because there he goes baby still
disappointed about March Madness Dickie
v in their learning goal from the three
i-formation heavyset Newton under center
this could be the game here this is
gonna be a big play play action down he
goes they bring the quarterback blitz
sis he's like break dancing
around him whoa so Colby you just jinxed
my overlord I tell now they're gonna
miss this field goal they have missed
three fields kickers been trash it's not
it's not Gostkowski is it who is it it's
gotta be know is he gone
he's gone dude this guy's sucks it's
Justin Ross while or or I'll ER
Phil goes up and it's good we're all
tied up we have a tied game both games
have been exciting and yeah man this is
why you tune into these sims more
exciting when you got a little bit of
money on it that bookie dad AG promo
code t ft Dylan a Gil wrath in the
YouTube ATC saying cams about the
Superman in the end zone and then this
next comment no yeah that's too bad
Sims will do that to you John the life
you were when they take it over in my
bookie three and a half Patriots are
favored - 195 on the money line ton
Titans plus 135 totals up to 61 and a
half
Wow we're already at 48 so people who
took the pregame over they've already
cash that people listen to our prop bets
you already cashed that briefs bringing
up the good point that the Pats kickers
that 3% guy from Marshall oh yeah right
yeah he's the guy who had that drafted
him the white power tattoo oh man while
he sucks at this game well that's what
happens the Aryan Nation can't help your
kicking game did there's no tolerance
for this game Sean big Wang wants to
know how a my unit is well big Wang my
shot at $200 we've discussed this before
$200 Sean and I so it's a bigger unit
big swing here got a stimulus check hang
on this game tan al under sent her back
to throw first in the 1000 and they
bring the quarterback blitz wow that was
a he gotta run them at the quarter wait
Tennessee has taken a lot of sacks it's
interesting New England's defense hasn't
been playing well but they've been given
a ton of sacks on Tannehill shout-out to
a list of plates by the way Alyssa play
it's big friend of the program I just
mailed them some custom SG bow lighters
that's very nice thanks nice and draw
play to Derrick Henry you can mail later
what do you work for the government yes
I did I didn't feel I was born saying
like I'm I'm mailing hazardous material
you know I want to get home on me a
bottle of whiskey and they told me that
I was gonna send him a bottle of whiskey
yes and they sent illegal yeah yeah yeah
the ATF told me that I can't do that
Tannehill down the course and what
could be gone to the 15 okay so just
update Corey Davis is now sim guy this
is his career best regards greatest he's
got over 200 yards he's got the whole
quarter he's gonna have five hundred
tweet at Corey Davis he's gotta come
check this out yeah someone's having
himself some games someone get Corey
Davis into this chat he's having the
best game of his career 10l run run run
run when down he goes and another set
this is crazy
hashtag tighten up this game is just up
and down all over the place exciting as
hell man that it probably should have
been a holding penalty funny powers
through it and gets the sack Kobe's new
ability to mush a player prime is gonna
be so fun to watch Tannehill under
center Brown in motion hands it off to
Derek Henry get outside he does oh wow
you don't see that depleted you're not
you're not getting Derek Henry off his
feet but the Titans ever even had like a
good receiver
no Corey Davis well who was uh ever any
more like back in the day that uh that
year they got to the Super Bowl they
have haven't Dyson yeah they had a
couple there's always a yard short day
late in a yard short come on over throws
it and another huge we've seen both
teams now come up short in the red zone
that's gonna come back and haunt them
down the line Big C go checking in wait
there's money on the you're damn
right man just go to my bookie dad AG
promo code TFT can pat on these games
in-game wagering you can fade me on
these games and make a ton of cash you
can fade the Dan to bass fires by your
lady a log-cabin
you know do a lot of things I love that
said Kobe's idea of romance is buying a
woman a log cabin here you go honey a
log cabin just whatever you know no one
can hear out here honey
[Laughter]
alright here we go
you called me we're in it we got him
right where we want him down three New
England and the Patriots they haven't
turned it over yet right except for the
black field goal
Tory Davis has like 300 yards receiving
Corey Davis is having himself a game you
want to hear Kolby perfecter Plex like
this or maybe not perplexed cuz I think
to point he's recapped what 9 how many
teams seven eight teams and you have yet
to find a team you were wrong about last
year on the wind total yeah has he
previews all 130 college football teams
on 130 episodes of the college
experience make sure you hit
head over to Apple Spotify stitcher shut
your goddamn mouth and then we finish
call me always interrupts his own purse
and download the ecology you ruined it
again I'm done I'm not trying it Shawn
Shawn but in first you don't know I'm
not trying to do when I talk it's not
considered interrupting yes Andy
well looting out of the shotgun first
and ten
donkeys lien motion dancer face sucks in
a do this
hands it off nothing there dancer bass
sucks and Sims but he knows his
with college vision he knows indeed in
fact I mean I I pop all the gas ball
finally another podcast the college
experience of course is the one that is
doing this but find me another College
College podcast that is breaking down
every single Division one team
130 podcast period yeah and I can hit on
on pretty much everything almost so far
i've like nine one and one or something
newton under center there and that'll do
it for the third quarter of thirteen
points in the third quarter
so looking okay for the man Pat's need
to step it up they are at home I'm Tom
Brady is gone this is gonna just earth
Bill Belichick if he can't overcome Tom
Brady noon out of the shotgun completes
it and he breaks the tackle that's
Marquis oh no that's a new again god I
first down to the 40 shim gauze helmets
adjust fire but he only needs a couple
more points to uh what was their team
total Kramer it was was it 10 or 13
Tennessee was 10 and a half
10 and after the second half so they've
already got 10 so you just need one more
point
Newton out of the shotgun first and 10
from their own 40 14 left to go
play-action Newton firing downfield me
completes it to Lacoste in the Tennessee
territory down at the 40 and of course
subscribe to the podcast hear that Jerry
Glanville episode that we just dropped
and our fantasy football preview series
the top 10 fantasy football quarterbacks
receivers already out and
ten fantasy football tight ends taping
top 10 fantasy football running back
Sunday so look for that on the feed
first and 10 out of the 40 Newton
play-action deep ball down the side guy
hits him in stride gods who is out of
control
sinew and Corey Davis are just bawling I
mean this new like I feel like there's
more touch on some of these passes the
game has changed shown let's walk in
this two unit Patriots over came out of
the shotgun he'll kick first and ten
from the 12 check sit down underneath
the Marquis league rookie doing dancing
around what you skiing look like he's
gone down moguls just like left to right
left to right go get a little chippy out
here yeah shox burrows is this football
all right talk second and floor
from the 7 clock continues to run 12:40
left to go you're listening the football
at tournament presented by the sports
Gatewood podcast Newton out of the
shotgun the second of four back to throw
to the end zone any drops it's you've
gotta be kidding some right in the hands
gotta be kidding we got it we almost got
another fight
Newton getting into it now well I would
fight my own team right there because I
mean what the hell was that
catch the ball bro how many great tight
ends of the head Hernandez coats Gronk
come on your hands you gotta you gotta
cans like feet that's what we used to
say for certain for another gigantic
they're down for the Patriots here at
the 7 yard learn to screw the so back to
throw out of the shotgun
cam has time to the end zone to nurse
short of the end zone but he did pick up
the foot oh we did it for contagious
Game six catch for Edelman 6 catch
bridle no and you're right on that
number and you could be in danger if you
had under on any of these player props
because if this game goes to overtime as
it looks like it may here's our over
here's our over dundies not let me look
Dan to face the house and every - it
it's up and job
register let's circle it on the board we
are now Sean we've already cashed four
units the Kramer gang is feeling good we
do have - three and a half with you
that's gonna come down to it but okay as
a Titans fan I'm feeling fine with great
great stop in the red zone our offense
keeps just has nice drives we just got
to convert if you're Tennessee it's
pretty simple hand the ball off to Derek
Henry and throw the ball to Corey Davis
don't do anything else
those are your only two plays yeah Manor
and they're working great Cramer gang is
a bunch of base or shadow heyday he's
just jealous bro and again if you want
to go to sports gaming podcast.com slash
a TC can find all the information on
tournament upcoming lines our schedule
everything you want to know for this the
football tournament hashtag TF t Titans
hitter came at the 8th
Nick okay punch him down to the 28 Colby
of course likes the punch and kick gotta
do volley throw a little dirty play
football you don't know what goes on at
the bottom of those pile that was always
what they would say it's like oh man I
get growing stuff you don't want to know
that was the best though like you'd have
like three or four piling getting
getting your oil check four players on
your team that had where dirtiest
it was just great football yeah you're
glad they were on your team and not
against you Tannehill under center hands
it off to Derek Henry
there we go he's way too easy to tackle
in this game that's why only cuz true
picks up to second and eight the live
number over at my bookie dot AG promo
code TFT Patriots - three and a half
- 195 on the money line Titans plus 135
64 is now the total Shaun
Tannehill out of the shotgun second and
eight hands it off to Derek Henry Juke
move there you get much going slow d7
Tannehill Ron loading
[Music]
here comes the foghorn in New England
it's a baby wheel man tan al out
of the second third and seven from the
31 hard count and he kisses her let's
guy to jump dumbass
it's Dumas I'll tell you what though
shot not nothing funny happened in the
pile of rug
as if something funny happened you just
get your hand bro it's called the scrum
third and 12 Thor Rock there's a lot of
different names for it Shawn
we can get into favorites to it I am a
man third and 12 from the 26 out of the
shotgun
Oh conservative Oh No Oh Eric Henry
would never run backwards like this
North China The OC of the Titans of the
hiram when I wasn't paying him on that
no throws - Corey Davis no thought in
spite of the fact that he's what 275
yards receiving you don't throw it to
him one time oh well that's normal
Sean are we get another overtime game we
could decent punt here by the Titans
Edelman has at the 14 spin moving down
he goes Patriots will take over at the
17 all tied up 22 727 this is the
football tournament
hashtag PFT presented by the sports
gaming podcast and my bookie dad AG
promo code t ft people just roll and
call me about John Elway I'm really
enjoying now don't let's not get into
that conversation no I know I'm just
people it's just one person under center
first and ten I throw to marquise Lee
pulls it down
Nunes about the same that's incomplete
what Wow - marquise leaves a boom yeah
Bob Sean I'm telling you we just we just
it's gonna be an overtime game I'm
confident of that does that overtime
five I'm worried about my one unit come
backer with you Newton out of the
shotgun delayed handoff home James Boyd
it was a huge hole oh man Titans are
lucky they got him down there cuz he
breaks that last tackle I think he might
be gone it wasn't even like a full-on
tackle
yeah yeah they just kind of got a little
hit on him he spun down fortunate then
he stopped there because he could have
he had room to run person 10 at the 33
Newton out of the shotgun
[Applause]
back to throw checks it down oh nice
Juke by James White and it reminds me a
little of Tom Brady just trusting James
White perhaps it's just the system up
there in New England sis Tom as they
like to call him picks up for second and
six really bad haircut brave will house
like his like his mom cut his hair in
quarantine Newton under center second
and six oh and down he goes and they
bring it we saw this on the goal line
who's on the sticks they really brought
a ton of pressure there sac Newton force
and a third and in trust me if it wasn't
him and I know 69 whiffed on everybody
but I mean if someone would have come
it's like 10 guys look at this yeah look
at this they have it to bring in 7
Newton big third down here third and 10
at their own 33 back to throw has time
who dangers throw would have been short
of the stakes regardless and now
Patriots forced to punt here with 8
minutes left to go we still haven't
gotten a Tandy Hill interception that's
just if if football gets canceled we're
swimming the entire season right I don't
know what else we would do dude assuming
assuming we live the mental I don't want
to I'm not even a football no I like
that I like I want to see where the
world I want to see what this one it's
like when you plug into the grid and
Tron I want to see what it looks like
inside the database oh that would be a
beautiful world man I hope so you know
Tanna back to throw a completes it to
Adam Humphries Santana Hill way too good
in this game what the he's done for
three days I know he's a hundred million
dollar man normally he throws for 394
like this season I have some goddamn
respect Garret Chino 18 wanting to know
anymore free play trivia to know who is
the current backup quarterback for the
Tennessee Titans
oh don't google it even though probably
people will google it I know this one
first one to get it in $25 free play
YouTube ATC chat room or the twitch chat
room whoever gets it let's go oh and
look at this formation to swing first
and 10 Jim Zorn coaching Oh a twitch
eyes motion I don't know what EA Sports
is doing over there getting some Matt
Cassell that's incorrect Cam Newton
wrong answer as well
backup quarterback for the Titans
there's one other one though if you sim
it they will come up yep dude how about
that baseball season they're gonna play
a game at the field of juice yeah just
like James Earl Jones and Kevin cos
there were road tripping although I
personally draft day was a better movie
Cramer I'm getting a little uh little
glitchy on my end I don't know if it's
just my computer everything looks
healthy with the stream Sean okay good
to know
Derek Henry picks up to second and eight
but it could be the goddamn kids are
they in there playing video
games you never know man we're getting a
little laggy put on some people are
people saying there's lag are they
with us no I think they're not
people here in Henry jeez
it's over there done stick a fork in him
it looks like it's cleaned up I went to
go to a sandwich spot today right before
the show I really liked the sandwich
Henry with the first down they're just
pounding this rock right now love to see
this kind of football and and Derek
Henry's the guy who gets stronger as the
game goes along and goddamn it called me
we're gonna oh oh go for a pick six come
on 400 yards all right three touchdowns
let's get the out of here sim well
let's talk about this with the like the
internet would break if Tannehill and
Cam Newton both went for 400 in the same
game same night dude hi mom would have a
heart attack
hieroglyphics all over the place on the
on the Twitterverse if Cam Newton drops
400 tonight Tannehill already got them
Tannehill under center clock continues
to run they hand it off to Derek Henry
lowers his shoulder gets the outside
clock continues to run doesn't pick up a
ton only one his brushing total was 88
and a half he's at 73 right now yeah I
mean I don't know which way it goes cuz
he really could break it at any second
come on blitz this piece of let's
hit him in the face Tannehill head of
the shotgun empty set
where's Claire Davis been there it is
dangerous throw all right field goal
over time loading feels like that's
where we could be headed I told you it's
gonna be over time yeah I'm impressed
that Tannehill has gotten through this
game without a pick six it's a hell of a
play with him Newton he hasn't thrown an
interception yet has he Kramer no none
of them has kind of dill at quarterbacks
37 yarder is up and it's good Tennessee
extends the lead to 32 27 of course
listen to the football tournament
presented by the sports game line
podcast ATC all things sports and my
polka-dotted Agee promo code t ft kramer
let's take a look at the live line hey
put me on the spot well Shawn I'll let
you know as soon as one surfaces oh my
goodness I'm being Astin yes yes I gotta
find all the taxis it logged me out now
I gotta verify myself what maybe it's I
got a captcha to locate all the taxis
I'm I'm a little inebriated I got
through it I'm pulling out there I'm
pulling up the sim sport odds the live
number the money line Patriots are now a
dog plus 150 Titans minus 240 I mean
wait Patriots are plus 150 on the money
line yeah yeah that's a bad value that's
going there down three at home
I remember gang one unit plus 150 let's
go look I'm not messing with anything
because I get Tennessee plus four and
six and a half so I'll take it Kramer
okay with me I'll take you coming with
me oh he's writing it down he's writing
it down the ledger oh wow
all right I think Edelman's still
sitting on six catches right I'm pretty
sure
Joey megamillions amigo is nice ball to
Lacoste the tight end out to the 38 and
his his number closed it either
six-and-a-half or seven depending on
when you bet it Pendleton I'm seeing a
possible charm straight oh you see what
I see you see that she's there Jace
plays are Manning the drone holding the
goat adios buddy
someone get rid of that guy Cam Newton
out of the shotgun first and ten
two-minute warning coming up wait - just
a new mine get an extra couple yards go
Kim
oh Jesus
this is unbelievable this is really
locked in for overtime if they don't
screw up the clock
well it's always possible Nutan out of
the shotgun get rid of it and he's gonna
do it down like the flag went away Oh
huge that was absolutely huge the
interesting thing is they they measure
the facemask from where it happened and
he was pretty deep in the pocket so it's
where the previous place started no cuz
lucky they're gonna they're at the 40
tip on what that's yeah that's
what I'm saying it's not how it works
person ten shotgun Cam Newton we need
like 10 yards with this kicker
three timeouts it shakes it down to some
new picks up for second and six clock
continues to run an interesting move
here if you're Tennessee what do you do
when a new call timeout I am zero
faithless kicker oh look at that jaw
you gotta get 30 yards that penalty was
brutal man cuz if you're a Tennessee
backer like me that sack was would have
been huge
Newton back to throw on second and six
Danny what's up baby that's seven so
maybe we're pushing right now yeah seven
476 because the OT Orange even looks
like a in this game dude he would
miss a 49-yard we need more yards my
problem with it I like he seems like
he's good guy to have on your team but
Jesus the second like he's already
kicking Tom Brady in the ass is
welcoming Camden came out of the shotgun
I said first and ten from the 32 shakes
it down underneath 86 who was a Derek
Siver's that's the asahi soluble
pronouncing that's the sassy ah see
that's a rookie Shawn knows because he's
a big big fan of all the tighten tighten
up while the Titans are standing up
we're strong if you got Titans plus
three and a half you're getting nervous
right now Newton out of the shack at the
second one checks it down to Ozzie Ozzie
again alright just kick the field goal
[Applause]
the front leg can't mess up this clock
man oh they have three timeouts but they
can totally mess it up you're right
but touchdown and then a pick six and I
cover all the votes well they can mess
it up by calling one right now so don't
call it right now Newton is due for an
interception eating cloth first and ten
knocked away James White had his hands
on it couldn't pull it down that slop
stops the clock and now Tennessee has
three timeouts so I think they're gonna
start to all their timeouts someone's
calling a timeout after each play wow
what a game Sean coming down to it Cam
Newton in the shotgun second and ten
think he'll get a first down damn it
don't do it
you aimin that's my first loss of
the day but my plus 150 moneyline stars
and elements celebrating no any hit is
over on his player props he knew he knew
that he had that chip I noticed it third
and three from the four so barring New
England getting the first down Tennessee
will probably have time to make a run
here in three timeouts third and 3 from
the floor Newton had the shotgun he had
white early rolls out to his left to the
end do it like I said oh my God all you
got to do is not throwing it you had
James White in the flesh at the
beginning wide open Derek Cameron legs
and a face mask to face mask
let's go this hashtag tighten up man and
much like the game in the actual 2019
NFL playoffs the game essentially ends
on a New England quarterback turnover
way they still have two timeouts
the game's over got over and they got
nine yards enough it's not over Henry
now the Patriots staying there Sarah
this is a good spot
second a one yard away get there there
we go
okay oh we will see we might see a Hail
Mary you're right maybe there is a
little more there's possibly hope well I
mean even the Hail Mary they're good off
the far like a hundred yards in this
game yeah it's probably overshot yeah so
anyway they might pass here was someone
asked why don't you guys head their
hedge Sean green cuz hedging is for
exactly 32 I would just run the
ball again make New England waste their
last timeout man that's it that'll do it
wow what an exciting night here I'm down
six units ago I am picked on D tomorrow
damage to that tomorrow Tuesday July 7th
sorry I don't even know what happy
fourth we're just we've been trapped in
the booth yeah happy fourth
enjoy your 4th of July Ryan's of the of
the nation's celebrate we are victorious
over the demons of New England and we'll
get maybe we'll get the leaderboard
going up tomorrow or Sunday sometime
that's the 4th they'll be up by the end
of the weekend relax national holiday
thank you guys for tuning in that was a
lot of fun shout to all the new viewers
over on the ATC youtube channel spread
the word tell people to come check it
out and get those bets in over at my
bookie dad AG promo code TFT gift that
deposit bonus up to $1,000 per make sure
to show off all the stats so that people
can get a take care of when it comes to
Malena props hit my Titans over 10 and a
half second half hit my Titans plus four
and six and a half against Kramer got
six of you units right now and now we
know Shawn the Tennessee Titans will be
heading to Baltimore to take on the
Baltimore Ravens and that game is gonna
be Tuesday July 14th 10:00 p.m. on the
east coast 7:00 p.m. on the west coast
and now Corey Davis a Houston Texans
they're heading to Kansas City to play
the Chiefs and that game is gonna be on
Friday July 24 at 8:00 p.m. on the East
Coast 5:00 p.m. on the west coast so we
have some of the debate the divisional
round is set for the AFC wow what a game
what a game indeed two guys who I would
have never bet would throw I mean
they're passing totals were in the 200
only one team threw an interception
they're the team that lost yeah that's
what it came down to and I said right
before having Cam Newton was due for an
interception cuz I am SG a K Shawn green
a K the sim guy showing off the stats
for all the player prop heads out there
I mean if you listen to me tonight you
made some money in the property I'm here
ten oh by the way Shawn we should say it
one more time you're welcome player
props are coming to the sim land I don't
even know if I like that Corey Davis
just on people Jesus and
remember if you want to get involved we
will be back on the mics the NFC wild
card night it's gonna be July 7th that's
next Tuesday first game
Shawn 8:00 p.m. on the East Coast 5:00
p.m. on the west coast the Vikings head
to the Saints and then the nightcap your
Philadelphia Eagles host the Seattle see
how game's gonna start around 10:00 p.m.
on the East Coast and 7:00 p.m. on the
west coast and that's when we'll be back
Sean it's awesome great opening night
again thank you everyone for tuning in
thanks for everyone everyone spreading
the word on social media appreciate that
oh my god fourth guy
1990 thank you he said thanks
commentators yeah shout out love
everyone peace and love to the new
YouTube friends peace and love to the
old friends over in twitch
god bless the USA happy 4th of July
thank you for participating in the
scaling podcast and for the sports
giving podcast I'm Shawn stacking the
muddy green and he is Ryan see everyone
next Tuesday and have a great fourth of
July
Kramer let it ride